a head nod is good that's not as good
how about just throw an egg white at his
head
i don't think it would okay we're hidden
live when you played football that long
you don't feel it
you got that ctd ctd
all right so we are live officially this
is what this is 44 is it 44
44 we got zenner in the house with us
got it happy to be here good to have you
back i think it's important for
everybody to know that
we follow a very important protocol yes
you come to the show
blue jacket white shirt apparently both
of you guessed that
blue jacket the valuetainment cult is
highly uh
organized here i came in with the exact
same look as adam except i had a pocket
square i thought i could either
take you know keep the pockets a little
higher i went to the car and changed my
shirt
i wasn't going to take any chances sick
pocket square by the way thanks
you guys look good so he he was looking
a little too liberal
with the white shirt and the blue jacket
and then he went double liberal
blue blue blue blue what makes it good
when you hang out with a guy
exactly thank god we have some balance
on the podcast so you know
shout out to all the uh the red white
and blue supporters do people even think
of that anymore i just feel like we're
in a non-political world lately which is
kind of nice
tom maybe you are buddy after after the
nonsense that just happened
give it give it 18 months don't worry
without a doubt right
yeah give it 18 months whenever the
terms come crazy stuff's gonna happen
gang
we are glad to be back one thing i want
to tell everybody that's watching this
those of you that come early with us
we are testing 9 00 a.m thursday i sent
an instagram
uh uh what do you call it a poll and i
ask 8 am or 9 a.m
70 at 9 00 a.m so we're gonna try
nine a.m this thursday instead of eight
a.m eastern time
eastern standard time let's get some
feedback
we've already done it it's eastern
standard time that we're doing we're
gonna test that uh test out the 9am
thing so
anyways let's get right into it a lot of
crazy stuff has happened the the meghan
markle
markle interview that's created a frenzy
drama
non-stop pierce morgan walking off the
set craziness i didn't hear about that
yet yeah excited to hear it 1.4 million
views on twitter in a couple hours
because pierce morgan just couldn't
handle it
he says i don't want to hear this
somewhere he just got walked off the set
now he has
you know he has done stuff like that
before it's not like it's the first time
so we've got a lot of things to cover
we got business things to cover reddit
has named its former snap
a former snap like snapchat executive as
its first cfo
this entire time reddit hasn't had a cfo
but they just announced they're getting
a new cfo score is joining forces with
jay-z music
streaming wall street isn't impressed
john mcafee
back at it again has been indicted on
federal charges
related to the fraudulent promotion of
crypto
currencies tesla is going to make it a
giant to plug into the texas
power grid and it could store enough
energy for 20 000 homes that's a big
deal jp
morgan posts 34 blockchain jobs as it
beefs up as jp morgan
coin elon musk lost 27 billion last week
but who's counting the biggest private
island for sale in the bahamas is about
to hit the auction block
and there's no minimum bid it's
interesting there is no me so meaning
you could buy it for five bucks
obviously not gonna end up at five bucks
but
it'll be interesting what happens that
young people are looking to spend
almost half their stimulus checks on
stocks
and then we got roku quibby rising
interest rates
senate narrowly passes the covet relief
bill mcconnell planning on an escape
hatch
in case he leaves senate before his term
expires
california theme parks allow to reopen
as of april 1st
good for california vegas benefits as
nevada eases some coronavirus rules
and then you know doom and gloom from
zoom
stanford researcher spent a year finding
out if zoom fatigue is real
and just how awful it is on our brains
and bodies and then a kobe bryant
card sells for 1.79
five million dollars i say we start off
with the kobe story
okay i say we start off with the
coasters near and dear to your heart
in many ways this is a little too near
and dear
my heart and so we have to talk about
this ca is there a way you can bring up
that picture of the kobe bryant card
while we're doing this so a rare kobe
bryant card
sells for 1.795 million dollars flawless
one of the rarest of its existence the
tops trading card
just one of two in the world at its
level of perfection
golden auction said it is the rarest is
the most expensive kobe bryant ever so
the cards condition
report to have perfect tense they call
it a black label which means
tens on the surface tends on corners
tens on edges and tens on centering
within weeks after his death brined
cards
were everywhere online increasing in
value by 600 percent
see that card right there go back to it
that card right there that sold for
1.795 million dollars tommy you want to
know a fun fact about that yeah that's
my card
except i sold it for 17 grand two really
that one card right
that's exactly the card i sold that card
ten and a half years ago for 17
dollars to an investor fast forward ten
and a half years later the cart sells
for
1.8 million bucks yeah how crazy is it
it's crazy you know let me take it one
step further did you hear what happened
yesterday anthony davis
of the lakers right yeah the most
injured
never never there i mean he had a great
season last year but this guy gets hurt
more than anybody his rookie car just
went for a million
one million his rookie card stole four
million yes anthony davis's rookie card
once again
one million so here's i want to get this
on tape on file right now
pat why don't you take you know a photo
a crypto photo of your gretzky card
of a picture of you holding this and
your other gretzky card and
your most valuable and make make the ntf
of it right and then and then
who who knows what that could go for i
mean seriously
you got to be you got to be thinking
about jumping into that too it's
unbelievable
i mean it's just a strange time you know
when cards are selling for the prices
that they're selling the main question
right now with cards is the fact that
is it gonna keep going up or is there a
crash coming up with cards
historically what happens with cards is
they go on a run and it's a very
aggressive run people just all of a
sudden are like oh my gosh i'm so
interested
it goes up and then there's quiet for
five six seven years
and then there's another run this is
historical what happens with cards so
if this trend continues when the market
takes a bit of a dip
and a market's not making people you
know millions of dollars left and right
there's going to be a bit of a dip in
the in the sporting cards
how long that's going to be no one knows
if it follows the trends
in the past that's what's going to
happen but what are your thoughts are we
in the middle of this run right now is
this what's
absolutely we're in the middle of it
right now let me tell you if somebody
said to you like he said anthony davis's
card sold for a million bucks what was
your reaction your reaction was like oh
ridiculous
but it's like happening every day brady
just broke a record for the most
expensive card ever sold wayne gretzky
broke a record for the most expensive
card ever so for hockey bradys was an
nfl nba is uh luca doncic
4.6 million dollars on his birthday mlb
is uh the mickey mantle psa 10 psa 9
that just sold for 5.2 million
i get a call on sunday from a guy he
sends me
he facetimes me i'm having lunch i'm
like oh facetime let me finish up lunch
i got food in my mouth
i said i'll call him back i called him
like i said what's going on he's like
i i got to talk to you i got to talk to
you so what's going on no no
listen this is very important he says my
son's uh
my son's dad gave him a gift with all
the cards and and i got to show you what
i got here and he opens it up
he says how much are these cards worth
what do i do with this and it's like all
these kobe bryant rookie cards right and
all this stuff that he has
legit cards no legit cards and then he
shows a mickey card
uh do you know if there's a lot of fake
mickey cards is this a fake one is this
a real one i said whatever you do don't
sell it for into anybody even if they
pay 10 20 000
just find out if it's a real one go
through psn and see what's going on
people are calling their grandmothers
their mothers their
grandfather saying where did you put all
those cards i had ma
where are they do we still have it in
the basement because it may be worth
millions of dollars today
i would hear stories my dad grew up in
detroit and yeah i mean
not that that's specifically relevant
but you would always hear
like in the 60s or whatever everyone was
collecting baseball cards this is when i
first started
here you know i was a kid in the 80s and
you would always hear like oh i had all
my cards in the basement and grandma
threw them out
you would hear stories like that i mean
did are you familiar with stories like
this absolutely you would hear them and
hear them in the same thing you said i
gotta go find mine so i found
a bunch of my cards that i had that i
probably gave to my
parents to put in boxes when i went to
college and
what what you didn't realize at the time
is make sure that they're the psa 10 and
the corners and the crease
because you could have an amazing card
and if it's not in perfect mint
condition it might
be worthless versus a million dollar
cart you know let me know when there's a
market for beer cans because
growing up where i did i didn't have
anything to do but play sports
and pick up empty beer cans in the ditch
were you drinking them
no i was a kid you would not believe the
beer can collection i have and i'm not
joking so if it ever gets to that man
i'm going to buy that island in the
bahamas let me say this about the cards
it's going to keep going i mean this is
going to be an abnormal ramp up
it's going to go higher and higher and
higher and then what i think is going to
happen
is you're going to get too many mediocre
anthony davis type
cards that are overvalued so then i
think it's going to come down
but those premier cards and the luca
donkey
and whoever it is you know the steph
curry rookie card
any old classic lebron card or thing
like that for for
those guys it's always going to be there
also is there going to be some sort of
market for
average people to do this through like a
mutual fund for trading cards
that's already right that's starting too
so i think you're going to have a lot
more people that are going to want it
especially because people are looking
this
as quick easy money and it really isn't
but it's unbelievable to think that
we're spending this much time
talking about trading cards that you got
with a pack of gum back in the day for a
buck
you know what now like my son is at that
age dash he's 12
where he collects cards always has and
by the way he found a luca donkey that's
worth over 200 bucks
you know good for him but that we had
but you can't buy cards now you go to
target they're gone you go to walmart
you cannot find them on the shelves
people know when they're stalking them
and they're gone that day
so there is an unbelievable interest in
it right now yeah i don't think it's
going away i don't think it's going away
because you know social media
again you said something very very
important here's what you said
anything that's a one-of-one anything
that's of
a limited amount of production is going
to keep its value
anything so the luca was a local man
one of one there's only one of it in the
world that's going to sell
the black label anything you find that's
black label that's a decent
i got a yesterday i got a black label
one soto rookie card
juan soto he's got a big upside could he
do good could he not do good i don't
know but it's a black label 10 of 10.
i got a black label uh uh a few months
a couple weeks back of giannis a black
label giannis that's going to do well
so the pops have to be low if the pops
are high it's not going to have that
kind of an explosion
with a card and then you just need to
know they're not reprinting them it's
not like
they're going to wake up and you know
someone's going to come from the feds
and say we have decided to
print 200 000 cards of the 1986 flea or
michael jordan so we're going to print
and the quantitative easing to increase
they're not going to do something like
that was that your jerome powell
interpretation no it's not powerful that
was the green screen that was out
all the principles all the printing
presses are just printing money
for stimulus so there's no more actual
way to print it let me uh let me let me
just weigh in because i agree with tom
there's something the fractionalized
shares it's it's available in stocks
rally something called stockpile and
stocks but in ra is that the name of the
company rally's one of them yes i spoke
to the founder you might not be able to
afford a
million dollar anthony davis card which
is absurd to me or a zion or a giannis
or a luca or whatever it is
but could you put 10 grand in and just
roll the dice like uh like
if it's a one of one yeah you're
probably not going to lose
if it's a one of them and and you need
to know like here's how this
works if they're con currently playing
the upside
is faster like for example lucas cards
sold for 4.6 million michael jordan's
card sold for 783 738
but lucas card there's only one of them
in the world michael's card there's 320
in the world psa 10. so
you have to know what do you mean
concurrently playing right so
currently we're currently playing okay
or
or for example if you own a
if you own a mickey ps8
910 you own a babe route 1933 gowdy if
you own a maze if you own a
old magic johnson bird rookie card
because the documentary if you own some
of that stuff that stuff's gonna be fine
but like i bought a zion yeah for a few
hundred thousand dollars
okay that's what that's going for yeah i
don't know what i i paid
i paid 350 for it i paid 350 000 for it
there's only
it's a it's a legit card it's a night if
i keep
it for a year two years if zion becomes
who
he could potentially become that could
be a two three million dollar card
but if zion gets injured that's a fifty
thousand dollar card a hundred thousand
dollars and you lose your investment and
you lose your investment
but i know that's the difference between
investing your money in small cap
mid-cap large cap you put money in
amazon right now what's going to happen
with that amazon's a two trillion dollar
company
amazon becomes a four trillion dollar
company what's your stock award it's
just w
right but what's the chances of amazon
going from a two trillion dollar company
to a 20 trillion dollar company in the
next two years
you're trying to ten excess money a
hundred actually so you need to put it
like i'm
i'm very much on value stocks and cards
like stuff that i like a will
chamberlain rookie card
you know high graded psa eight will it's
gonna be willed
you know it is what it is you know you
got a ruth a ted williams a ty cobb
a honest wagner those types of stuff are
going to keep their value
but if you want some risk is this small
cap cards today
you know two quick points i think i
think the interesting thing to watch
with this too is because
this is feeding on itself there's so
much media coverage every day
there's tons of stories every single day
on this people want to be in they want
to know more so here's the next
evolution of it i think corruption
you're going to have counterfeit
you're going to have theft and you're
going to have murder i really think with
these valuable of cards out there
but that's been happening all three have
been happening okay all three
maybe even at a higher level now by the
way by the way fyi
like you know for me why i am very
careful buying artwork
i have a thing about buying artwork okay
i watch this documentary
about two years ago on our way to
croatia i don't know
on our way to monaco and i'm watching
this documentary
about this con artist who sold fake
paintings i don't know if i've talked to
you about this before is this the
picasso
have i told you this thing right okay so
the guy goes
picasso is about to die he's on his
deathbed this guy who's a con artist
goes to a local guy who admires picasso
says i want you to paint something with
picasso's painting style
he gives the guy 500 bucks he goes to
picasso says a local painter who admires
you
did a painting i just want to get your
advice on it how you like it he wants to
really get your opinion
he takes he says i'll meet with you
meets with picasso picasso looks at it
says it's okay
so as you mind if i take a picture with
them to tell them that you like this
picture says yes
he takes a picture with picasa picasso
dies a year later he comes out and says
here's picasso's last painting and he
sells it for millions of dollars right
so when it comes down to painting how
can you verify the validity of a
painting
yeah the creative right so you cannot
verify the validity of it
but when it comes down to cards there is
a grading service
that what made this game legitimate is
psa
and beckett they made it legit because
when you buy a card
can you uh can you have sam uh
can you have sam can you go grab me the
rookie card uh
grab giannis or grab me some of the ken
griffey's grab me all the griffies yeah
grab me
griffies and janas so when you get a
card and you see the grating on it
that's what you say okay i trust it so
trust is what brought it back in the
early 90s
if you bought a michael jordan like when
you bought the honest wagner card
it was cut yeah so there was a lot of
fraudulent activities a lot of fake cars
so people like
i'm not even messing with cars so you
just spent a hundred thousand dollars
buying a car you realize a month later
it's fake
so you yeah step away from the game the
guy i bought the card from
the wayne gretzky card from great guy
you know what happened to him
bad experience got burned he says i want
to have nothing to do with cards
stepped away he got a half a million
dollar check i turned around to two
million because he was burned out yeah
so it does attract people like that so
when you get in
get in prepare that you may experience
some bad yeah but you have such an
advantage because you've been in this
game for a long time if you think
there's going to be an easy buck you
can't just come in there
with the level of knowledge i mean
you'll just get crushed yeah did you let
me ask you this you know
the one of one card is that a random
thing where someone opened a pack
and there it was it's like a winning
livestream inside a pack of coins
so so you can like uh ken golden from
golden auctions
this last weekend he had a
record-breaking weekend he was all over
squawk he was all over the news
everywhere he's doing interviews right
they sold nearly 40 million dollars of
cards in one weekend
40 million dollars in one weekend is
what they did
their revenues last year was 100 million
dollars they just raised 40 million
bucks kevin durant was part of it all
these other guys he and i were texting
back and forth
he is helping the market because he is
bringing attention to the market
rally is bringing attention to the
market the players are bringing
attention to the market
lebron james's card sold for 1.8 million
you know who commented in the comment
section
he says guess who has two of these cards
yours truly
lebron the card that sold for 1.8
million lebron said that's two of his
own cards he says i got two of them
myself so it's like
even the players are buying their own
cards yeah like for example okay so
griffey let's let's talk about this
this is probably a five thousand dollar
card okay you can get this probably five
forty five hundred dollars to five
thousand dollar card you wanna know
what's the problem with this card
it's been printed two million times
there are
two million of this out there and i
think 3 000 have been graded at a psa
10.
if this was only 300 greater than psa 10
this would not be
a 5 000 card this would be a 200
000 card a 150 dollar card now is this
still a good stock long term absolutely
because of two it's ken griffey's best
rookie card right sweetest swing in
baseball
sweetest swing in baseball so you go you
have to know also the print of the cards
the timing of the cars
like you know bonds and i you know
bo jackson there's story behind him he
didn't grab janice because giannis
it's giannis so you can't even he was
looking for the wall he's probably like
what the hell is honest i don't see a
single guy's name here would work
it's all good so there is business dude
if you listen to it just like stocks
just like bitcoin just like
don't go jump and i did a video about
cards a month and a half ago it's a good
educational one before you go in
if you do go in go in with a group of
people that know what they're doing like
i had even you said the other they pat
out going
10 grand with you 20 grand with you and
you buy it with somebody that knows what
they're doing don't go
in all by yourself because if it doesn't
work out for you you're going to come
back and say oh this doesn't work out
for me
and two quick points before we move on
um
you brought up fractionalized shares
single stocks like single car you know
how i said what a rally rd
this is a shop so like i don't buy
single stocks i buy index funds or i'll
buy mutual funds or you know
i i can't project the next big stock and
just it's very hard this is it like you
can buy a share of the honest wagner
card
okay okay you can buy a fractional share
like the wayne gretzky card that i sold
they bought one of them for 720.
and they put it there for 800 000 you
can buy shares at a hundred bucks it's
like owning the green bay packers that
you can have a share of that i have a
share of the packers that's
interesting you say that so you can buy
a share of
the cart it's a great system for
individual investors do you
like what's your advice to people out
there me obviously learn get familiar
with what's going on first of all would
you buy one card or would you buy a
shares of multiple cards
like a mutual fund or you just like go
all in on asylum no
no no way i would say go all in on one
player right
if you do because it's emotional and
you're part of the city and he's in your
city i get it like let's just say you're
you know kobe comes into the lakers he
gets trader for vlade divac and you're
like oh i feel like he's going to do
something you buy stuff because he's
emotionally tied to you
gotcha i get it but if you're you're
trying to do it from the business
standpoint
just look small camp mid cap large cap
what does small cap mean
biggest upside injury prone right mid
cap somebody who's playing
it's in the middle of their career but
they could win a couple championships
and they can go up for example
giannis is all if ryan has got her
tomorrow his he's
his career's still been a solid career
he's won a couple enemies he's gonna be
he's right but if giannis
goes and all of a sudden he teams up
with a luca they get on the same
same team or he goes out there and gets
a robin
and they went back to back-to-back
championship giannis is something else
so
and then there's large cap what's a
large cap you buy a car that you know
it's going to be going around i mean
just
lebron is absolutely a large cap a kobe
is a large cap and mj is a large cap
a ruth is a large cap that's our large
cap cards that you know they've already
been validated they've already won
multiple championships they've already
got a great career
people already know who they are that's
a large cap you're not going to lose a
lot of money this
may not explode this higher and this
could explode but it's got a
bigger risk i think it's important for
you just to kind of come full circle
here
tell your experience with the kobe
bryant because you kind of left
some details out meaning you bought the
kobe
bryant for like 10 grand whatever it was
sold for seven so you're thinking oh my
god i
made seven quick turnaround for 17 grand
at a time
yes when i sold that card what people
don't know like when i sold that card
um i was running the insurance
we'll do it here and we'll put on
shortcuts i was running my insurance
company php
is i come home jen has her situation
with the baby we lost the baby and then
we have my half a million dollars of
savings that i put into it
that half a million goes down to
thirteen thousand dollars wow okay
this is two thousand ten two thousand
eleven ten eleven years ago
when you're just starting out please i'm
trying to figure out how i'm gonna come
up with money so i still
we're living in an apartment to save
money at the time 2010.
i sold everything i had anything and
everything to invested into the company
so we did the math the other day and i
did it in front of you
that 17 000 i put into the company made
me 14 million dollars
so the point is i may have lost on a 1.8
million dollar review but i put it in my
business it saved the company
it helped us getting to where we're at
and obviously right now it's a complete
it's a sick story
for those of out there that feel bad for
patties but i tell you one thing i
understand for the person that sold it i
understand they almost didn't want to
sell it
and i understand for the person that
bought it they're so happy to hold the
card yeah there is
there's a the person that won the card
can't wait to hold it
you don't even know if you're a card guy
to hold
a card of a kobe like that bgs 10 black
label
i can't even describe if especially if
you're a collector
if you're if you're not a collector you
don't need to say tell somebody
yeah i went to the super bowl man and i
tell you this harrison guy
took the fumble away before halftime and
ran it back on kurt warner
and then at the end kurt warner makes a
comeback but the steelers still end up
winning and it was crazy because
kurt threw for 400 touchdowns you should
have been at this place
oh so who won yeah but it's you don't
understand this was sick
and he was like dude i don't follow
football yeah why would you tell me that
i wouldn't have told you the experience
so if you tell us like somebody watches
this right now with cards i like dude
who cares about cards if it's emotional
the guy who buys the kobe
he hangs on to it he's gonna say mom
look hey dad look hey guys come over
he's gonna have a party sharing the
cards with people
showing it to them it's a pretty cool
experience and you've been on both sides
of the equation meaning you've won on
some deals and you've lost on
clearly this works that's how life works
you're not going to win them all you
know you're going to have some and
the reality is i've i'm going to tell
you crazy thing i've never lost on cards
how weird is that wow how weird is that
like even that kobe situation
i never lose on cards because i sit on
them
if you sit on cards the only way you do
is if the guy does something that's
like a guy comes out with steroid
scandal and then
his car no one wants to buy the car like
you didn't wake up this morning saying i
want to go buy an o.j simpson rookie
card you know what i mean
so so there's an element well sure you
probably keep emotion out of it which
you know you know what you're doing
which plays see i have a philosophy i
only invest in
ball players like lamar's kids you know
lonzo
and lamelo that's it i think they're
going to the top well i would i would
steer clear of the jello card the melo
is
going that guy's going places he's a
special kid okay so there you go
first story we got uh uh cards
second story do we want to go into the
meghan markle story and see what
happened there
we know you do i mean i listen it's it's
what everybody's talking about it's what
everybody have you guys had a chance to
watch some of the highlights
i've seen some of the clips so you tell
us your so give it give us the rundown
and whatever i want to hear from you
what do you think about the whole thing
when you watch it what is your the uh
because there's two three different
sides of the story where are you at and
who do you believe she
she goes on oprah yeah uh and she does a
sit-down interview
now was the interview just with her and
then harry popped in at the end or
yeah harry potter later on so you know
uh
more than super bowl so there was more
people watching the interview than the
super bowl
96.4 million viewers
watched uh somebody however recording
some animals were explaining
intensifying when somebody
those under ratings drew higher numbers
than the super bowl
if you watch it you couldn't there was
50 commercials every two minutes
every time you're watching the
interviews commercial commercial
commercial commercial commercial and
apparently they didn't take any money
that was transparent right up front
oprah said to make sure everybody knows
have you gotten paid for this
zero and do you know any of the
questions i'm going to be asking she
says i know none of the questions you're
going to be asking and do you believe
that
of course why why do they need to take
money for the interview they're making
so much every word i
believe oprah is a goat so oprah is not
somebody that would say something like
that it's oprah you're sitting with
oprah who's got harper productions a
billionaire you know you got to give her
the prop so you're sitting with somebody
that dude i'm not
giving you any money for this because
i'm going to give you the eyeballs if
you come with me right
so that's the numbers that's what
happens so here's
my three biggest takeaways from this
because i'm uh
no i think she's beautiful i absolutely
think she is
gorgeous out of everything that's what
you got number one singing so
you didn't see the interview just like
she's so beautiful
i don't care i believe you i'm just
putting that out everything you're
saying to the atmosphere if you want to
know like just
my thoughts on on this princess i think
she's beautiful now here are the three
my three biggest takeaways
number one during the the hoopla the
drama of her being in the family the
royal family
at what point she went just like a
business she went to hr
like there's a human resources in the
freaking
palace to sort of complain about this
situation here i'm not sure how
far that went right um number two which
is
you know say what you want she was
legitimately having
suicidal thoughts which you you
you're marrying a prince you come into
this royal lifestyle and next thing you
know a few years down the road you're
having suicidal thoughts
you're dealing with paparazzi you're
dealing with the drama even harry said
this is very reminiscent of what my mom
was going through princess dye
who in my opinion is a goat like an
oprah type
and then thirdly which was sort of the
biggest controversy and they wouldn't
name names
they the family wanted to know how
dark-skinned
baby archie would be when he was born
because she's i think mixed half-half
he's obviously a ginger
i think they're thinking please tell me
this kid don't look like blake griffin
we hope not so
shout out blake griffin but um
yeah yeah i don't know i saw it yeah you
saw that right there looking like a bag
of cheetos right there but
that was pretty controversial for the
family like and
i i'm not sure if it was stephen colbert
just went to the network yeah yeah yeah
yeah
play great the nets are going to
probably win a championship this year
but anyway side note
um shocker the royal family
in the the the greatest imperialist
country ever to exist
might be a tad racist when they might be
so um there there were some
definitely some drama going where you
had thomas you know and the racism card
is what's being played a lot right now
the biggest loser in all this is adam
silver in the nba
they had their all-star game that night
their big showcase cbs destroyed it it
absolutely destroyed it in the rating so
they go head-to-head and that's got to
scare the nba
one of the biggest winners gail king she
deserves a raise at cbs her best
friend's oprah
she gets the interview over there they
had to pay seven to nine million in
licensing fees but gail king
kudos to her you know um this was a
total recipe for disaster for the royal
family when meghan markle entered the
fan
uh into the family because she was a
celebrity she's wired for ambition she's
an ambitious individual
all right she knew how to play this
status that she was about to get
and she wasn't a huge celebrity but she
already had the hunger and the drive for
working her way up
in the showbiz world and making it in
hollywood you know i don't blame her at
all i saw this coming i didn't think
this would work with harry eventually
it's the worst case scenario for the
royals because they're all about
tradition
and conforming and consistency and
honoring that crown
and keeping that whole thing going right
and she's about um
i don't know any about this in my
history i'm thinking about myself and my
family
and and clearly harry is all in on board
with her
i went in thinking that i was going to
be anti meghan markle on this
thing that uh like she was being
opportunistic to a negative degree where
she was really taking advantage of this
but i bought
some of her stories that she was talking
about and you know they got to hollywood
and they've already signed a nine-figure
deal with netflix they have a hundred
million dollar deal
with netflix to produce documentaries
and entertainment
they have a huge podcast contract so
they're making a ton of money
but this thing's gonna get crazy because
this is the last thing that the royal
family needs and this is the biggest
story and it's an american
that's going to do this damage to them
ultimately and then if you want to talk
about pierce morgan
which is a fascinating story right with
him storming off the set of good morning
britain today basically the version of
good morning america but do you know his
backstory with megan
they met for 90 minutes they sat down
they talked they got you know they got
along and there was something going on
yeah they they they were they got it was
a relationship this was back in 2015 and
apparently they really hit it off they
were having a pint
and maybe another cocktail or something
and according to pierce when he tells
this story they really hit it off
he must have had something for her
probably right he puts her in a cab
after that
she goes to a party and that's the party
she met harry at
and he said that she'd never talk to him
again so there might be some
really deep rooted personal feelings
there with piers
and it all exploded this morning which
is only going to keep the story going
because he walked off the stand he
swarmed off the st
said he took off his mic exit stage
exactly what megan wants
oh my god so this is just playing bigger
what the pierce morgan uh part of the
story is that
what happened this morning he's
defending the royals on you know what
he's defending what happened this
morning is somebody came in
on the show and called out peers this
guy doesn't like the weather guys
the weather guy does not like piers at
all on good morning britain
on good morning britain kind of called
him on he said well you don't understand
how challenges this has been to
have been megan and harry and all
they've gone through of being part of
this limelight and how the media has
trashed them and the media has not been
friendly to them outside of the wedding
that's pretty much what he said
and then pierce like i'm not having this
he just walked out yeah
and the guy said and he's he's a king of
publicity stunts that was a brilliant
move by yes
pierce is a genius i mean you have to
realize he's a genius
oh there's no question about it he
understands marketing
let me say that part i wouldn't say he
knows pythagorean theorem
but i would say he is a very good
marketer and he knows how to put a story
out there so you can't say no to it you
don't find him annoying at
percent all no no i didn't i never but
but i just want to get your
you ever met an annoying genius like
it's yeah it's over there they're
sitting over there
they're our friend genius comes in many
different colors they can be jerks they
can be annoying they can be
attractive they can be ugly there can be
a lot of things so let's go back to the
story yeah again
do you have sympathy for her uh i do not
do not i'd love to hear you let me
explain where i may and where i don't
okay so here's where i'm at with uh uh
with the interview so i watched the
interview and i'm going through i'm like
okay
sounds good opens up hey we're not
paying for it you're not doing this it's
open to any questions
great she starts going into the story
well you know
what happened with this and then oprah
showed some stuff you know katie
had the bump and they're like oh wow
look how she's appreciating the bump
but when uh uh you know megan will put
it how look she can't get her hands off
her bump
i mean that's just true you can't do
something like that or then hey
here's katie eating uh
guacamole or avocado and look how
responsible she's been with her health
and then the same story
with megan eating avocado look what
she's doing destroying water and all
this
and you should see these articles it's
pretty bad when you compare it you're
saying that megan was getting the raw
end of the deal
megan in uk was treated like trump was
treated in the u.s to kind of give you
an idea about how that was true the
treatment was
she couldn't do anything right right i
fully agree
kate middleton was getting all the love
and kate middleton
because kate middleton was like i
understand the traditions et cetera et
cetera yeah well she's british
kate is more so so it's not about
so grace kelly if you tell a story about
grace kelly do you remember grace kelly
yes who was great
actress the famous actress who was much
bigger
than megan megan wasn't at the level of
grace
grace i've never heard of meghan markle
that's the part yeah yeah suits was a
good show
yeah but not i don't know if she was on
that show guys guys there's grace
kelly and then there's she's not
angelina jolie no not scarlett johansson
comparing to angelina jolie the only one
person you compare to
when you're selling a house or you're
buying a house or you're buying a card
what do you look for
comps the comp is the only fair comp is
who
grace kelly it's not princess diana it's
grace kelly okay so if you compare to
grace kelly
grace kelly was graceful grace kelly
came into the monaco family she's like
hey
here's had her own identity she still
wanted to do
her own things what she didn't like
later on if you go to the museum and
kind of
learn about her she still wanted to do
acting
you know one of the bigger directors at
the time who was the bigger director
that did
uh hitchcock i don't know if it was
hitchcock one of them reached out to her
it was a guy that she had already done
movies with before
says i want to do another movie with you
and she says i can't because the royal
family
she says i want to do it so he convinced
her she went up to them they're like you
can't do it because now you're part of
so she's like finally she says okay i
won't do the movie which makes sense you
are now part of the
royal family you kind of know what
you've gotten into maine on the other
hand
you know she's been married before a lot
of issues with her husband
ex-husband when she was with him and you
know and again this is what you read
about right i'm not somebody that knows
i haven't interviewed everybody to know
about
uh everyone's stories her and her dad
didn't speak for a couple years her dad
got a letter from megan that she was
thinking he was thinking about going
public with it every 30 days he said i'm
going to bring it out bring it out until
she
contacts me so apparently there was
something going on with the dad
and a lot of people in hollywood you
know maybe didn't really get along with
her for her you know
pompous attitude a little bit it's which
what people have said about her now
let's go to the interview back to the
interview oprah's doing the interview
and they're going through it a couple
different things came up one was the
baby
one was the bump uh the other one was um
uh how when archie when when she was
pregnant
they said we're not going to provide
security for your baby
or a title or anything or title or for
the baby which by the way
do you believe and every time oprah
asked who said that
they would not who said that no she
wouldn't say that she would say it's
what i heard
it's what harry and others told me so
it's nothing
ever that was direct she would deflect
and say it's what harry told me it's
what harry told me it's like when you
don't want to go buy a house
and i'm talking to the husband it's like
oh i love this house it's great but your
wife isn't here
and i say so do we want to make an offer
and you say what let me
let me speak to my wife let's call her
right now
she needs to see the house first right
so she would deflect it's a great uh
uh skill set of a client to do that
it's so let me talk to my wife let me
talk to my wife let me tuck them up it's
great i've been through it long enough
to know that this is a normal process
when you're selling so she kind of
deflected on harry hey let me talk to
harry hey let me talk to harry
hey it's what harry said oh so you
didn't hear this no but
harry told me and someone told harry so
there wasn't
credibility about whether the kid was
gonna get security or not
protection or not now here's the thing
amongst us
do you actually believe they're not
going to give the baby security
i don't believe that because if you
don't give
the baby security who are you making
look like an
idiot yourself imagine the publicity
stunt if you didn't provide security for
the baby
okay imagine that now do i see
something like that taking place and
saying hey you know let me tell you what
happened
we're not gonna you know what what if we
don't give him security oh you know what
your baby doesn't even
so imagine like some kind of a challenge
and argument took place
and then she says they threatened to not
give security
yeah but that's kind of like saying hey
you know what i'm gonna do to you i
wanna kick your ass dude i'm not gonna
kick your ass it's just something that
happened so
we don't know where that went right we
don't know that part of it again we just
have to believe what she's saying
in this interview then there was a part
where
um you know a conversation about megan's
baby
is of color you know like you brought it
up a little bit at the beginning
and uh you know there's this awkward
part of the interview where oprah
winfrey says wait
what yeah who who said this and megan's
like
it's like a five-second pause in the
interview wait
you mean to tell me somebody said that
do you think there was a part of this
because of race
she's not answering then oprah says
well if it's this i mean if it's the
first
baby that could be of a different color
coming in
maybe that makes them feel uncomfortable
and she says
well uh her words if that's the
assumption you're making
it's a safe assumption to be making do
you understand what i'm saying
so it's kind of like i answered it
without answers no she says it that hey
oprah if that's the assumption you're
making that's a pretty good assumption
to be making so
look you know you when you're around
folks long enough and you sit down with
people you kind of know
how to you know sell and market on all
that and then
later on hey she asked for help that
part i actually believe and the reason
why i believe that part is because
you know um in in business and life
whatever you want when sometimes you get
it not everybody can handle it the
limelight is not for everybody
because what comes with the limelight
what comes with the limelight
pressure expectations focus
trauma okay pressure of what though
expectation of what so actually think
about expectation what are the most
annoying pressure and expectation that
comes out if you become
famous and you're in the limelight i'm
talking like highest level like
being exposed things like that such as
what so actually process it one is looks
look at her she's getting older look at
the skin look at this so the judgment is
hardcore on what what you look like
right what else is it mistakes mistakes
judgment on your past past
marriage what you eat what you do
everything literally everything
everything is in ghoul you're in a glass
box like you're being looked at judged
reviewed so if you go from
grace kelly had it and she was the same
so it's not like
the day she got married to monaco and
she became more famous no
she was famous the day before she got
married she was famous a day after she
got married
megan was here she went bam yeah right
the world now so i can see that
happening you needing to talk to
somebody
i can actually see that part i can play
a little counterpoint to you yeah and
it's funny how you can watch the same
interview and maybe get a little
different take
number one when she said i'm gonna refer
to harry
maybe i looked at it like she was
protecting that person that said it
she didn't want to expose her him at
that time
she already said that i would have never
said harry because you're also
you're also putting the responsibility
on harry you're dividing harry with the
family
that's the one person he did that when
he moved to the u.s no that's not the
point no no no no you have to know if
i'm if i'm putting it on you
i'm i'm i'm almost making the division
between you and your family wider and
wider which it just shows maybe you are
who people say you are maybe you are so
everything the blame was on harry she
didn't take any of the responsibility
she says
it's what i heard through harry it's
what i heard through harry she said that
three times
i'm a guy that's a diffuse unified glue
she was dividing
him and the family hardcore yeah that's
how i read it and then the security
aspect too i think
part of that was security for life and
she was worried that maybe when
the child got older archie got older he
wouldn't have that security down the
road
probably protect him as a baby i have
three quick points number one in 2011
when um
when william and uh uh and kate
middleton got married we did a book on
that we partnered with access hollywood
i wrote this book on the royal wedding
it was the biggest thing the book
was very successful it's sold three
years ago in 2018 we were going to do a
book
on this one right the new royal wedding
and we had to pull the plug on it the
day of the wedding there was just
no interest wow it would have been a
complete disaster and we had a good
media partner with it too a very very
big celebrity gossip site
but there i was stunned at the lack of
interest in that thing so we completely
had to pull the plug
or we got crushed i'm gonna make um a
quick prediction here
this is gonna rattle prince charles like
nothing else
because i think in his mind he had this
succession formula in place
i think he figured he'd be king a lot
sooner than now right who knows if his
mom's ever going to pass on if he's ever
going to be king
i think and here's my prediction he's
going to do what nfl stars do when they
go to another team
right like an emmett smith goes in place
with the arizona cardinals what does he
do
he comes back to the cowboys signs a
one-day
contract so he can retire as a cowboy i
think when prince charles when the queen
actually dies and
prince charles becomes king i think he's
going to do it for a month
ceremonially and then he's gonna turn it
over i think they need
younger monarchy there i think he's
gonna put william
on the crown i'm gonna he's gonna make
him king
and and the other thing is this really
hurts harry's brand doesn't it i mean he
used to be this fun-loving macho
cool dude and now he's just taking
orders from everyone
megan oprah the queen his brother he
just seems weak in this whole thing
and i agree and he's come to the united
states but you know what i bet they have
a really good life they live in beverly
hills
they have a huge deal for netflix she's
going to have that creative outlet for
her
satisfied they can have more kids and
they're going to be relevant they're
going to stay in the public eye
as long as they want to oh the the the
playbook for what they're following
is a great playbook don't get me wrong
it's a phenomenal playbook they're
playing
but it's also because you're part of the
right family you wouldn't have access to
that playbook if you weren't part of
that family you wouldn't about an 11
million dollar house
if you weren't part of that family it's
not like he was a lawyer when he started
a law firm sold it for 200 million
dollars took his exit and then he went
and bought a house
and you know the money comes because of
your last name
and your lineage there's got to be a
little bit of respect being given to
the family that gave you that success
there has to be some
as competitive as some people maybe with
their like
bill clinton okay whoever bill clinton
may be
his mother had issues a lot of issues
a lot of issues if you study bill
clinton's mother
when they ask them about his mother he's
like well listen
you know you have to know it's my mother
and i love her and you know it's been
you know we all have issues but it's my
mother and you know she raised me and
i'm so thankful for that
he never answered the question he just
kind of went and gave that respect to
i there is a challenge like there is not
like we're talking about anything
catastrophic here that happened that
they hit or
you know anything that's manipulative
that took place right
you got to pay some respect to that
family to me megan
is not even the issue to me i don't have
any problem with making megan's like
look hey harry
i don't want your life bro let's just
simplify this
i don't want your life i want to be me
i've been me my entire life if i don't
like it i don't like it
making could divorce him six years from
now she can move on to a completely
different life
that could easily happen the part that's
a little bit
uh disappointing to see is when i see a
son of the family allowing this to
happen where the public humiliation
is the family okay the public
accumulations from the family
that's the only part that i see i i i
you know
it's it's uh it's the only challenge i
have with that yeah he had a choice to
choose
the family and the history and the crown
or his wife he went with his wife
but wait a minute that's not what i'm
saying no no no i'm not saying don't
choose your wife
i'm not saying don't have a little bit
more no i'm not saying don't choose your
wife
i didn't say don't choose your wife i'm
saying choose your wife
but when you're choosing your wife you
have to say i hope you realize this is
who i am and i i have to respect the
family i'm respecting yours
you got to respect my family guys we
can't hear you sam turn off your mic
okay i respect your family respect mine
we can still hear you so so we have to
respect
the family that's all i'm saying if i
marry
jen hey my family has issues look i
understand
i love you i want to marry you i want to
have kids with you like when my wife my
wife and i were getting married the
night before i got married i had a
meeting with my mom
and i sat with my mom and i told her for
30 years you've been my number one
tomorrow you're my number two she's my
number one
wasn't easy but i have to tell her it's
my marriage
but i have respect here's what's going
on here i think that part was a little
bit that
uh yeah but it's such an extreme when
it's monarchy and it's that tradition i
mean harry
literally had to make that choice
because he moved all the way halfway
across the country but make the choice
but say
we don't need to publicize and throw my
entire family
under the bus the whole show is about
throwing the family under the bus
yeah if you choose to get married i
fully get to move wherever you want to
go i want to leave the family
but don't do an oprah winfrey show with
a hundred million dollars trashing
the reason why you're living next to
oprah winfrey if you weren't in that
family
you don't live next to oprah winfrey
because there's got to be a little bit
of
it's the same exact thing when americans
who are raised and born in america
who go trashing america and how terrible
of a country america is
rather than paying some respect and
saying hey man i was lucky to have been
born in america some of us weren't born
into this incredible country some of us
fought like crazy
so there's other people on the other
side saying dude if i was part of that
family at least
show a little bit of gratitude that's
the only challenge morgan is going to do
a pay-per-view he's going to do a
counter point interview in england it'll
get
huge ratings record numbers someone has
to take uh get their side out of this
yeah i i i don't know pierce morgan
annoys the hell out of me but
back to back to harry because i think
you guys are missing
one point with harry um i actually think
that the guy has a spine and he has a
backbone and he's doing what he thinks
is right and i don't think he's
disrespecting his family like meghan
markle
just did this interview solo status and
she did it by herself
and harry wasn't there that to me is
like
he wasn't there for the party but he
threw him under the bus harry wasn't
there but then he came in and said all
right i'm here now
what's up but did you watch the
interview it was a solo interview with
her did you watch when he came in like
he said what's up did you see it
yeah yes hello cheerio yeah what's up
yeah of course of course yeah
but he came in and and validated
meaning they were lock and step like it
wasn't like she
listen he's running the show in my
opinion i don't think she's the boss
what gives you the idea he's running the
show look listen when she showed up
she wasn't like all right uh you got a
new
sheriff in town harry take a back seat
i'm running the show i got the family uh
i i think he's running yes i think very
much so here's wrong you are the only
person in the world who thinks this
okay so he's this one i have contacts in
the monarch here but
i know so listen but give me proof what
makes you think
i just think so i just think look when
she shows up yeah
you don't think that he's like look this
is my world welcome to it
what no it's not how do you not think
that that conversation has seen him
trash her family have i ever seen
i don't think that's irrelevant to me
it's more like that's what she's doing
to him
he is very well aware of what she's
doing where did he get his wealth from
where did he get his wealth
listen you can do both you can have
respect for your family but at the same
time call out the [ __ ]
obviously his family where did you get
your wealth from solo
solo you did it okay so you're self-made
yes now imagine if you start off with 50
million bucks from your family
okay but that's a if the same regardless
of family he's also he's also commenting
on
culture tabloids listen you gotta you
gotta remember
he lost his mother to to some of the
craziest i'm okay with that okay yeah
i'm okay the guy the guy
diana guy i'm a fan of that what i'm
saying is the guy has a spine
meaning he has like you might not agree
with how he's handling it
or the you know how he's choosing to
throw his family under the bus so be it
but he's like look i have one life i'm
seeing things that i don't necessarily
agree with with that whether that's in
the monarchy
in my family in british culture and the
tabloids
and i have a i'm a man i have a wife i
have a family i'm gonna i'm gonna
put my fist down this is what i believe
and if that's okay nobody has a problem
with that but pay respect to the family
i think you can do both but he did not
he allowed his wife to do a show with a
hundred million people trashing his
family
well maybe he everybody he tried to call
his family and they wanted to take his
car every everybody that happens in
families have you ever had somebody and
talk to for a while do you go and do a
show for a hundred million people
hey family i haven't spoken to my mom in
a few weeks
you're gonna go do a show say mom how
come you don't call me look i don't i
don't
i don't care about you know whether or
not
you know he stays or he leaves that's
none of my
that's not the uh my position here do
what you got to do you're a grown man
but if you're doing it say hey here's
what i'm doing i'm leaving
we have to respect my family because
without the family we don't
let me ask you this i think he's saying
no no he's not saying it if they don't
have the royal family you think netflix
signs a hundred million dollar contract
tom of course not okay let's see adam
because i'm curious
well obviously it's the whole freaking
premise here but that he's part of the
royal family but do you think
if they're not part of the royal family
to get a hundred million dollar contract
but they are part of the road you're not
answering the question what do you mean
yes or no i'm not understanding the
question he didn't come
from that lineage if he didn't come to
the limits we'd be on the next story
right now
he's not would netflix give him 100
million bucks obviously not
okay so the point is give some respect
to that but he is
but he's not i think he is i think he's
a responsibility give me the point
though
give me his wife trashed his family
publicly
his wife called his family racist not
caring about suicidal his family she
called his family and breaking news
maybe they are if maybe they frickin are
and this is him saying let me
look we can't continue like this let me
ask you a question disrespected my
entire does your dad have certain issues
he did yeah he did does your mom have
certain issues of course you marry a
wife
yeah she goes and shares your dirty
laundry of your parents you're okay with
that
depends what the like it depends on what
give me what depends
meaning there's limits to what you're
willing to take listen you guys are
being super disrespectful yeah
like if your mom was disrespecting jen
to the point where it's like she doesn't
people are this family uh tico he's
that's it no title no nothing at one
point do you have a conversation and say
look
okay well then this is what we like
what's this is where we
differ in values and principles this is
where we different values and principles
let me tell you i don't know a single
family that doesn't fight
doesn't argue doesn't have issues
doesn't have bitcoin doesn't have any
chance there is not a family doesn't
doesn't have that
not one family that doesn't have that
zero every family
if you sit there and talk to them
everybody thinks their family's like oh
my gosh if people really know what my
family was like
we all have a ridiculous family none of
us have a family that walks on water
okay
and we all have dirty issues that if
people find that like that's your mom
that's your dad that's your family yes
that's my family
but it's my family we work here
there's walls here we have issues we
have differences we have problems that
happens here
it's our business we talk about it we
hash it out
we move on it's going to happen many
times you don't go to the public and say
let me tell you what happened yesterday
when patrick let me
we're dealing with it here is what we
got you keep it in the family
i have no problem with you leaving zero
do it
no problem believe and the message is
i'm grateful for the family we have made
a decision to not discuss any of our
affairs with our family
like michael jordan would say michael
tell me about your personal life
hey you got questions about my kids you
guys got questions about my personal
life
i don't answer those you got questions
about my game you got questions about my
business matters i'll answer those
he made it very clear with the media
today people salute
mike this is not a good look to say
let's become famous by trashing our
lineage that gave us all this money
it's very unattractive to me that's all
it is yeah and it's on harry because
she's
she is who she is i can't wait to see
what kind of content they produce to see
if they've got the chops i mean because
netflix doesn't just hand that money out
they're not a charity
so they they are the pressure's on them
for really to crank out some desirable
content and we'll see if they can
okay if you're watching this if you just
saw us going back and forth adam's got
his own positions i got my positions
tom's got his positions
we're all somewhat different okay do you
uh do you think megan
sharing her stories she was
a a major you know they were in the
right move to come out and do what they
did
if yes comment below i'm curious do you
think no i totally disagree
they should have just kept it in the
family moved on i also want to hear your
thoughts comment below to see what
you're saying about this
dialogue that we had the last 30 minutes
about megan and harry i hope you're
going to be okay by the way
i hope it's a little emotional yeah i
know you're a little emotional but it's
going to be all right
you're going to be fine just so you know
by the way uh if anyone uh
has any ties to meghan markle's sister
or anything uh
no i i see you with pippa pippa
middleton that's who i see you with
yeah i think adam is adam is sitting
there saying
let me get this [ __ ] if i can marry you
megan yeah if i get into the family get
a hundred
dollar netflix yeah oh that's exactly my
plate well
my i i lost out on my top pick that's a
good point
that's right i had it we were talking
and you know she wanted this so let's
let's talk about that so mackenzie bezos
uh ends up uh fairly quickly by the way
uh
uh leaving uh when they got the divorce
she ends up marrying
a school teacher one of her kids school
teachers right is that kind of what
happened
a science teacher so what do you think
about that since you have strong
opinions here why don't we give this one
to you i mean mackenzie bezos she was
married to
jeff bezos the richest man in the world
for what 20-something years yep
they get a divorce maybe five years ago
uh jeff bezos starts dating tom's good
friend what's her name
lauren sanchez lauren sanchez um and
megan who i'm sorry um mackenzie 50
years old
ends up divorce a and only worth about
you know
50 billion dollars something ridiculous
one of the wealthiest women in the world
she owns
what five percent of amazon whatever the
number is
and she's 50 she's not young but she's
not old
and she uh made headlines what over the
pandemic for doing what
just completely giving billions and
billions of dollars away
to philanthropic charities and and just
being a decent person that's
my biggest takeaway from her is that she
has just been
she could have been a you know typical
boca divorcee
and just you know shopped every day
alone
just you know that was offensive right i
i did offend some people but
she had an opportunity to be just a um
to contribute nothing to society and be
rich and you know live on a yacht but
she said
no i actually want to make a difference
i actually want to have a normal life
and give back to society and that's
clearly what she's done she's given away
billy what do you think about her
america's school teacher i think
kudos to this freaking science teacher
that put some sort of
chemistry concoction together and said
all right i'm gonna
woo this uber wealthy
bezos broad and uh
she uh she fell for it and good for him
this guy's name is dan
jewett and jan dan jewett is doing it
and doing it big tom i'm gonna have a
disclaimer here and say i don't know him
i don't know him so but you know what i
don't need to know him to have an
opinion right i don't
and this is a farce this is not going to
work this has
no chance to work zero and i'll tell you
why
because they're just completely miscast
and it might be all great now i'm
married the science
teacher i met him at school pickup in
the whole thing but this is not
going to work because they are too
different they come from two different
worlds
it never works look at elizabeth taylor
when she tried to marry a commoner it
didn't work it never does and i have a
friend
i have a very good friend who was
married to a very successful man
a lot of family wealth you know she grew
up
you know in high in a higher society was
used to that type of life
when she got divorced she had a
relationship with a guy who really
didn't have a job that really you know
kind of flopping around like to do you
know just like to have a good time
she got tired of always having to pay
she got tired of
having to carry him and i think any guy
would be a little insecure in this
situation
unless this guy is the strongest man on
the planet
i mean this thing will will start
fraying away
i mean don't you think jeffy's those
richest man in the world jeffy just
landed on the moon jeff bezos he's like
i'm just trying to land on my wife
tonight
his whole existence is to help her give
away the wealth and i just think it's
weird
i think it's weird she got married this
quick number one i think it's odd that
you know his whole
all everything he's saying is too
perfect for me now i could be wrong and
they could be perfect for each other and
just save the world but
it's a little weird to me i think just
to counter
a counter argument what you said clearly
she knew what she was signing up for and
he knew what she was saying like they
they knew
just like the harry and megan thing you
know what you're getting yourself into
and even she said
she changed her amazon author page
ironically her amazon author page
ironically i bought it
she lives in seattle with her four
children and her husband dan
that's her body she's guilty she's
feeling guilty for having
this much wealth i don't i think if she
she would feel guilty if she wasn't
giving it away i don't think she's just
the reason why she is i just think she
wants a normal life raise her kids she
lives in seattle
she know what she's getting herself into
with this science teacher i think the
biggest question is
how long is homie going to actually
teach science class like
like when one kid steps out of line he's
just like like i can't deal with this
crap anymore i'm out let's just go on
vacation
once the honey i think that's the
biggest thing is how long is he going to
be a science teacher for
you were a substitute teacher i was just
up to teachers yeah for a year ago where
were the billionaires for me back then
exactly there was no mckenzie bezos
popping into science class being like
hey
i think a guy once the honeymoon wears
off is just going to feel insecure and
thinking i didn't really have anything
to do with this
it's all her and and then and then
little things start happening maybe
you're a little short-tempered
maybe you're a little condescending
maybe you're a little snappy and this
and that and that just builds and builds
and builds
so i don't know i wish i'm all the best
but it just seems like a woman i wish
them all the best but they'll be
divorced in six months but that's just
my opinion and i'm sticking to it well i
mean
you just have to realize when you go
through a very uh
uh extreme relationship extreme meaning
abusive extremely lovable extremely
a prick extremely competitive extremely
attractive extremely whatever the
extreme you go you go on date you
typically are like dude
i'm so i'm gonna go complete opposite
side so then you typically go
like we went extremely politically one
side then we go extremely
one guy that tweets 50 times a day one
guy that doesn't even want to do press
conference
we are so extreme as human beings right
so do you want more extreme or you want
more normal
i didn't say that's this is not me this
is what mackenzie i'm just a regular
are you saying that you go from one
stream to another or go from no to one
extreme to just i want some normalcy
no no typically with an extreme yeah you
at one point valued that so if you
valued oh my
gosh jeff is so driven freaking this is
so attractive
right you know and they're like dude
this guy wants to go take out barnes and
noble and then you're like dude that's
attractive
it's like i want to go live on mars babe
that's enough i'm like i'm limited i'm
not good with taking up bookstores but i
don't care to go to mars like enough let
me just go marry a scientist that wants
to figure out
chemistry right let's go figure out some
of this benzene stuff so
so now she goes and marries a guy like
that you date a very very attractive
girl
who wanted you to get her gifts every
day and i demand a
dozen roses every single week like oh no
problem you're so beautiful
and then all of us are like bro i just
want to like miss one week of flowers
with you and not be judged for it right
then you go meet a girl that's just like
oh if you get me flowers once here i'm
so grateful for like why don't you look
so
so so there's an element that going on
you went from the richest man in the
world to a
teacher okay to a teacher now
you know could work it could work when
you're just kind of like going away and
just kind of kicking back and relaxing
but tom's got a good point it's going to
be very
there there is a reason why j.lo is
dating a-rod okay
there's a reason why jay-z's dating
beyonce jay-z is beyonce beyonce is
jay-z if that makes any sense a-rod is
j-lo j-lo is a-rod kanye is kim
kim is kanye there is that understanding
of what it is with the limelight you
know you've been trained on how to do it
this science teacher has not had
limelight except for
20 kids that are screaming his name's
throwing paper you know to
counter-argument that you always hear
people
in hollywood like i do not want to marry
another actress i do not want to marry
someone they say i want to just someone
who's low-key by the mother of my
children remember what you said you said
something you said you know
ever since i've been around your company
what i'm starting to realize the power
of couples
correct okay that's the couple power yes
so mckenzie
is there that's that's a different kind
of a
you know you have to know like mackenzie
who do you think mackenzie's met in her
lifetime out of dinner
everybody everybody are you kidding me
whoever she's missing
what i'm trying to tell you is she's met
every who's who so who do you think
impresses her
nobody can imagine you're like oh
mackenzie tonight i'm going to
take you out to dinner
and i'm going to introduce you to the
number one realtor in
all of such-and-such county it's like
bro i own the company what are you
talking about
he works for me you know yeah so there's
it's not going to be hard to impress you
know
you take a girl out the first time to
europe she's like oh my gosh tom this is
such a beautiful place you take a girl
that's been to europe 50 million times
right okay let me take you to the
restaurant you follow me guys
so there isn't that i want to get that
yeah right you know i think i think
they're doing it for the right reasons
okay i'll give them that
okay you know but but you know it's
already come out that he
had played a big role in her diving up
that four bill that she gave away at the
end of last year
and i'm just thinking how are you
disqualified to be telling her what to
do with the money
jeff might be thinking as well you know
i'm the one that kind of built this
company and earned this money now
they're not going to pull him up
so let's see what this guy looks like i
just think watch him have like a
ridiculous six pack and runs ten miles a
day
yeah let's let's let's get a little say
something about this there's
something called human nature and a guy
doesn't want to be taking he doesn't
want to be taken care of
all the time is that him on the left oh
boy
he's just a dude he's a dude wow
she looks happy we must be related
that's a very similar nose i recognize
that
he's the armenian uh science teacher
that uh good for
us well i mean look she looks very very
happy yeah
holding her kindle and you know
obviously they're uh
hanging out somewhere there but uh pat
you you brought up something so i'll
just circle back to that like
when you when you when you deal with
four years of extreme by the way he's
still upset with megan just so you guys
know
go ahead clearly distraught um but
you know the whole thing with with biden
you know not to get too political here
was
we had such an extreme personality such
a showman such a marketer such a yeah
look at me look at me it's all about me
news kind of like megan yeah so go ahead
i don't know about that but i think
there's a lot of people craving in this
country like bro just
just just shut your mouth get off
twitter just interesting i want i don't
want any of that
stay aligned with your points here my
points are intact sir
my point is you're intact here's my
point is that this country
a lot of us a lot of people 80 plus
million
we're like dude just enough of the drama
i just want something a little more
chill
again not too political back to
mackenzie i think she was like look i
dealt with the guy who wanted to be in
the truth
adam 15 minutes ago and then changes
with me like what is the
matter with you my point is completely
concise
i think she just wanted a normal chill
life she married the science teacher oh
my gosh she'll never have a child she's
gonna be all right
she's running carpool pickups she
definitely has a type of bald guys
you figured she'd go with a guy with a
full head of hair she wanted to be she's
consistent yeah we respect that
galera should have sledded in and said
eric had a shot editor
so let me let me give a shout out to a
couple people nicole crean krino gave
five dollars and said megan just
guaranteed the crown has a fifth season
harry is a soy boy
millennial men don't understand honor
nor heritage okay
yimi mourinho uh uh have you all seen
harry in afghanistan have you seen harry
in afghanistan or no
well back in the day when he used to go
yeah okay and then we got the
cove 12x12 i still can't believe topic
of the day is royal family and not how
people are being brutalized in china
okay very interesting there that's a a
shout out to us talking about china
rot's child owned the royals and the
media you're being duped into focusing
on this fact
actual problems and then cafecito break
we should protect our family and work
out our own problems privately bringing
out family drama attracts chaos
does this help build up relationships
you know what good for you cafecito
break but uh
okay so next what do you want to talk
about next what do you want to talk
about next you pick it adam how about
you pick the topic
i think we got to talk about your boy
john mcafee
you've been telling my job i think i
think you have a personal experience
with this guy
he's all over the news crypto bitcoin
blowing up interest he's an interesting
guy and he might be facing life in
prison so
john mcafee let's hear this story i know
can you pull up the interview with him
and i
where he pulls up the gun i think it's
like 43 minutes i don't know the exact
time that's what i want baby i want that
story so anti-virus
magnet john mcafee has been indicted on
federal charges related to
fraudulent promotional cryptocurrencies
cyber security mogul
uh and former presidential candidate is
a variety of charges brought up by u.s
department of defense
uh his executive advisor ranked and him
and his executive advisor raked in more
than 13 million dollars from investors
through a variety of means related to
cryptocurrencies the first scheme was
scalping
also known as pump and dump when
mcafee's cryptocurrency team allegedly
purchased large amounts of
digital coins at low prices knowing that
mcafee would then endorse them on
twitter
this is exactly what my concern is with
musk by the way what i talked about the
other day
this is my concern with musk that he's
playing with fire he irritates the wrong
person they could do something to the
guy
they could do what they did to trump to
him the first king was scalping
and it dumped okay mcafee then allegedly
recommended such coins without
disclosing he owned them
finally the cryptocurrency team
allegedly sold the cryptocurrencies
following temporary price spikes that
were generated by mcafee's tweets
a second alleged scheme in which mcafee
and his team members use mcafee's
twitter account to promote initial coin
offerings
without disclosing they were being paid
to do so if found guilty mcafee 75
faces a potential maximum prison
sentence that would amount to a life
sentence yeah
thoughts let me let me get your guys
guess on
number one how old do you think he is
well i think he's 75 i think i read
75 correct just said okay um
at his peak what was his net worth and
what do you think his net worth
is now peak was 100 million okay yep
what is it now less than five million
bucks
you're absolutely right yeah he was
worth a hundred million dollars at one
point i think he sold his company to
intel uh mcafee security if you ever go
on your computer
you know your anti-virus work today
right something insane right company
plus
yeah 20 billion right ridiculous it's
owned by intel he sold it
cashed out you know 20 plus years ago
was living his life now he's worth quote
unquote
four million dollars okay so anyone who
was worth a hundred million dollars at
one point built this ridiculous company
um was doing whatever the hell you
wanted to do and now you're worth
basically four million bucks
what kind of desperate measures are you
willing to do what kind of pump and dump
schemes
are you willing to go along with well
just get back in the lineup you spend
his money partying hardcore
the guy partied like he was dan
bilzerian before there was dan bilzerian
he was
the original playboy if there was social
media when mcafee doing what
what mcafee was doing mcafee would
probably have a hundred million
followers today
his life what he was doing was
ridiculous in the 90s 2000s 2000's
you ever seen this documentary i've no i
don't recommend seeing this documentary
if you don't like to see
weird kinky sexual desirable things
that's not my style
very conservative if you then you may
want to watch actually if you actually
like what he does in his documentary
that would say a lot about you
you know what my first impression is
exactly what you say with your
experience with him with the documentary
and everything he's a weirdo
i mean he you know he's he's got this
genius thing going for him
in a positive and negative way but you
know let's get to this case
you know um is he guilty or innocent it
seems like even marcia clark could win
this trial i mean
this one seems really really obvious it
centers around this uh cryptocurrency
called cether
right where he said he told the feds
that he had no involvement in it
whatsoever
but the same day he privately wrote to
the seether's founder
quote for the next few weeks take my
name off your site i want to be able to
leverage my twitter with people assuming
i have no relationship with you
so there seems to be a smoking gun in a
real trail here so he's already
in custody i think isn't he i think he's
in custody he's been
hiding in belize and then he went to
guatemala so i would imagine
you know his goose is cooked he's done
they're probably going to get him and
it's over i would imagine this is the
final chapter for him that would be my
prediction well he's already been
all up in the news headlines for tax
evasion that was prior to this
yeah but do you know why he got arrested
on the island he was living in you know
the whole story no tell the story you
actually know the story i do not i want
to know the story no okay this is cause
he is in custody oh yeah
so he goes and gets this house beautiful
home
and where belize and i think it's belize
and his neighbor is a guy that got the
house right next to him
because he wanted to retire he just
wanted to have a peaceful life so then
he shows up mcafee is your neighbor
he had a pit bull in the backyard this
pit bull would bark
non-stop nonstop mcafee's dog would bark
non-stop
non-stop nonstop and the neighbor says
you got to do something about your dog
i'm trying to have a peaceful
life here for retirement your dog's
going crazy
so what what does the neighbor do the
neighbor says uh gives the
people a poisoned steak
he poisons the steak gives it to the dog
murdered the dog mcafee comes to the
back and sees his dog dead
he says you got to be kidding me this is
the story
he sees that he hires somebody locally
to go take the guy out
he takes the guy out wow allegedly and
then he tries to run out the
country and he got arrested et cetera et
cetera that's one of the stories but
you know the guy's guy he's on edge so
we showed up to his house
if you want to pull up the video so we
show up to his house i'm in the car
i'm having a call was it 43 minutes 43
minutes i'm in the car
and i'm uh uh what do you call it
talking to tom
and mario says hey pat you may want to
you may want to come suck because these
guys are freaking out there you're
parked outside on the phone and the
car's still on please turn it off i'm
like how long ago was this interview
i don't know three years ago where did
you do it tennessee
yeah so they go may 7th exactly you know
34 months ago right so
i'm in the car he says come inside i
said what happened he said we just got
frisked and so the guy
our camera guy at the time he was
frightened he's like what the hell is
going on luis right he is
purely panicking okay so i finally go
inside and say hey what's up say hey
how you guys doing they're good so so
tell me about your story what do you
want to know about my story i'm a vet
oh really what were you stationed at you
know i was stationed i was in
navy seal and a ranger one's guys the
navy someone got rachel i said no way i
was at fort campbell kentucky
really what was your most i was a 63
bravo what unit were you at
three two six engineers okay this
[ __ ] knows what he's talking
about he's like
we won't kill you come on man bring out
the whiskey so we go there bring it up
he said listen man we got five
prostitutes upstairs you want to go
i'm not even kidding with you so i'm
like yeah i appreciate the offer it's
okay
thanks so much
rain raincheck and i'm sitting i'm like
but like dude you know so we started
these guys were
really cool guys there's 10 ak-47s on
the table oh my
i'm not even kidding with you 10 ak-47
these are his security guards
these are security guards there is at
least
10 german shepherds outside okay and
then all you hear
is this sound
like like a chain massive sound of chain
like i have no idea what's going on it's
the garage opening but i've you've never
heard a sound
as if it's a seven ton garage wall
whatever that's open
so it opens up it's like oh shoot he's
here the dog start barking that's
he's here he's here so i'm waiting he
shows up
he has a gun on his side when you see
the interview mcafee fully loaded okay
he has whiskey he's smoking while he
does the interview in the middle of the
interview somebody knocks on the door
one of the guys jumps up goes to the
door with a gun seeing who's at the door
in the middle of the interview you just
got to see this to believe it because
this almost sounds fake but you got to
see what happens here is he going
through
see the guy russia
pat does not even move look at the gun
the thing
go back a little bit go back a little
bit to show it again with the doorknob
go back 10 more seconds
russia you've got 50 different options
to watch watch or even direct flights
first knocks on the door the heck is he
going through
um russia see the gun to make if he's
right
so um yeah who was the guy that knocked
on the door who knocked on the door i
have no idea
for me to say is he good is he bad i
don't have all the facts
you did not even flinch no what am i
gonna do did you think that that was all
real or were they
showtime for you oh no way it was 100
real they were
paranoid at the highest level from the
beginning to the very end
uh because at that time he was going
through something as well where they
were after him and he
they didn't give us the address to his
place until two hours before the
interview
didn't give us the attitude where was it
like in the tennessee hills or was
outside nashville
two hours outside of nashville there's
only two buildings out there what are
they worried about
i was in nashville and then you know
we're trying to see if we can get mcafee
and they said and then you go into the
it's literally in the boonies when you
go to this place
gotcha and then we sat down we spoke and
i have to tell you it was actually
a very good conversation and the
craziest thing at the time bitcoin was
like seven thousand dollars he made a
prediction saying bitcoin's gonna go to
forty eight thousand dollars it went to
forty eight thousand dollars
yes so two years later he said it was
gonna happen by the end of 2018 but it
ended up going to 48 000
so to his credit it ended up going to 48
but it's a very very interesting
individual what's your biggest takeaway
from the interview
and where it is currently in the uh
media this is my concern with crypto so
exactly what happened here you have to
know that exactly what's going on here
is happening with cards
and when you're able to manipulate
crypto because so a guy goes up
okay imagine elon says bitcoin is the
future
okay so if you bought bitcoin let's just
say elon and i'm not saying he did or
he'd not but let's just say
somebody connected to him buys bitcoin
at 30 000.
bitcoin is the future goes to 50 000. he
dumps he says
i'm not that cool about bitcoin now it
drops to 40 000. oh we're doing one and
a half billion
so elon elon has to be
he's the genius genius he's got a very
high ranking of a genius obviously
but uh you know you have to be careful
if you think you're untouchable
the way you become untouchable is you
typically have upset a few people on
your way to the top
if they decide to do something you know
you just have to be very very careful
when you're not too much look at trump
hey you become a president by doing what
call on everybody out
then you become a president at least do
what you know
calm down a little bit right and what
does he do keeps it going double down so
what happens kovit doesn't happen the
guy gets re-elected so they shut it down
yeah states take a hit he doesn't get
reelected you could have taken a
slightly so that's the only thing that
i'm concerned about ilan because
elon is one of those guys that he can
bring so much
innovation and progress and technology
in other ways he's
he is a very important figure now keep
in mind nobody's bigger than the league
of course yeah but he's a guy that in
our era he can do a lot of
uh positive uh you know he's positive
impact he has absolutely no margin for
brevity or doing anything that might be
light-hearted because every word
he puts out there is taken to such an
extreme i mean i ca
you know the sec is watching him he's
already gotten their attention what he's
doing with dogecoin and with everything
else but man can you imagine waking up
knowing i can't have one moment where i
throw something out there
harmlessly because it's going to be
taken to an extreme and it will affect
markets
it will affect lies it will affect jobs
you know he he's so fascinating right
now
you know like we talk about trading
cards wouldn't it be cool if you could
invest stock
into personalities like a musk like a
bezos like a buffet
who's going up who's going down that
would you know or trading cards for
these guys
i think that would be really cool too
but you know it's it's
every day and the level of brilliance of
musk just yesterday
we find out about this big solar or this
big electrical thing he's doing in texas
you know then it's spacex then it's
doing 25
um tunnels in miami it's just
unbelievable the other thing that about
musk
which i find interesting is imagine how
many smart people work for him
he hires the most brilliant of the
brilliant for
every one of his companies but they
don't get any credit
how do you hire guys that are that
brilliant but have no ego
everything goes to him he gets all the
credit all the time
i wonder if that affects anybody down
the chain very interesting point by the
way
and he's he has to be the masterful king
of recruiting
all right just to get what he's getting
to stay one step ahead of
everybody in every industry and you know
what he probably you know they talk
about tesla losing its value and i don't
want to lump a whole bunch of categories
into this but do you think he really
cares
because he's got three other things and
his biggest play in the future is going
to be
power anyway it's going to be battery
it's going to be electricity that kind
of thing
so he's five steps ahead of everybody
but the one thing that could take him
down is one careless tweet
because that really could be a a big
problem for him
and and and who is sec that's my only
concern it's not even
my worry is and so the good thing about
milan musk is the fact that he can't
have a run for office
unless if they change the laws which is
actually a good thing for him to believe
it or not
because he was born in south africa yeah
but but but the challenge for him
his enemies his enemy is not jack dorsey
his enemy's going to be
sec that's who he has to keep an eye out
the regulators
okay the regulators have to keep an eye
out and for anybody else that's kind of
watching
that's you know on the on the crypto
side that you were thinking about the
pump and dump
you're gonna see how quickly stories
like this hurts crypto people
this doesn't help crypto people so
correct so so i don't know if this makes
sense or not
the folks who are in crypto don't want
stories
like this you want legitimacy you want
normalcy you don't want stories
exactly so let's give the legitimacy
story to the crypto people and let's go
to jpmorgan that just posts a job
posting that says they want 34
blockchain jobs at the beef up
jp morgan coin right so us mega bank jp
morgan chase
has 34 open block change uh job postings
on its website it's quite possibly a
record for any company
company in the crypto market many the
job related to onyx onyx
the division created last october to
oversee jp morgan coin
uh a search for blockchain or jpmorgan's
courier pages actually brings up 56 open
positions with 34 including the
the tech and the job title in contrast
to this goldman sachs
which recently said it's starting a
crypto trading desk
has this has just two blockchain
cryptocurrency job openings morgan
stanley has also two
by the way two to 34 that's 17 times
more when you see this what do you think
when you see this
adam what do you think when you see this
kind of stuff with jp morgan hiring 34
goldman 2 morgan 2.
yeah i mean it's this
we just talked about legitimizing
bitcoin yeah you don't want to see a
story like mcafee out there
because you know years ago uh
not too long ago when you thought of
bitcoin and crypto it was all
illegal drug dealing you know
shady type stuff and now it's gone
mainstream right like
it just recently hit a trillion dollar
market cap it's come down a little bit
but it's at 960 billion dollar market
cap
the whole thing here is legitimizing and
making this
cryptocurrency mainstream and the
cornerstone behind bitcoin is
this blockchain so when you start to see
companies like tesla
and square and visa and paypal and
everyone kind of
accepting this and tesla pumped in you
know five percent of its cash reserves
1.5 billion dollars
and then you start to see these you know
big time banks jpmorgan chase
um look for
you know opportunities to basically
enter the states like they're building
their
jpm coin it's ridiculous and i don't
read too much into
the fact that goldman sachs only has two
potential positions because you talk
about it all the time
that they only have 400 advisors across
the country whereas a merrell might have
5000 right so
what's the numbers on that you talk
about that all the time so
it's just this is mainstream it's
legitimizing everything that's going on
and you're just sort of weeding out the
bad
the bad apples like the mcafees of the
world we're trying to get involved in
pump and dump yeah i think this is a
huge play for jp morgan i think if
you're a client to them you've got to be
really feeling good and knowing that you
got some smart people leading that
company
they say that they're not looking just
to hire for 34 jobs they're looking for
experts
they're going to singapore they're going
to india they want the best of the best
of the best
you know you mentioned some of their
competitors i mean someone has to
dominate in this space and they're
saying it's going to be us
they're planting their flag in the sand
and it's a really really smart move
saks like you said has two job openings
uh bny melon has four
i i guarantee you the ceos of these
other companies when they saw this are
going
oh [ __ ] they're owning this space not a
good look because there's a finite
amount of talent
out there for people that do this kind
of thing if you go after them and say
i'm going to get the 34 best in the
world
everybody else is getting scraps they're
going to dominate because of this
aggressiveness i think
you're not buying bitcoin though no no
you mentioned this what do you mean i'm
not buying meaning you're not
like no it's listen some people missed
it i'm in the category of missing it
anybody that got in early on the bitcoin
side and they bought it at 100 bucks or
200 bucks or 500 bucks
guys said the other day my friend bob in
2007 500
of bitcoin the guy is a deca guy right
now right and from 2007 to today
yeah no it's it's in the direction we're
going i always believed in the
technology
i thought the regulation would come
sooner i thought the regulation would
come sooner
where somebody like a janet yellen is
going to come in and participate and
kind of make it a little bit ugly but
look
more power to the bitcoin community for
getting this kind of publicity that
they're getting specifically with
companies with smart people like
jp morgan chase morgan and goldman that
are
entering the market you talked about uh
janet yellens of the world jerome powell
um chairman of the fed recently came out
and he's basically said
that they're looking into the crypto
space
um not to um
you know take away the the prowess of
the dollar but to complement it
and i think it was 86 of all
central banks are also looking to this
across the
the globe so um and when a
central bank implements a currency that
is
it is like companies don't have to
accept it like bitcoin uh
tesla doesn't have to accept oh bitcoin
they can make a choice no question
but if a federal reserve of a european
bank comes out and says no we're
accepting this now yeah
it's now the law of the law it's
official it's official it's official
referee
now it determines the pricing of it now
it's going to be
is it priced right it is is it
overpriced is it going to go higher is
it going to go lower no one knows but
you know it is
it is something that is official and
there's nothing you and i can do about
it it's here yeah for sure
crypto's not going away and you know i
have a good friend who's in this space
who's really kind of an expert in it we
did a story with him
and vt post a few weeks ago and he
really broke it down you know like it's
not like these businesses say hey we're
just going to start accepting bitcoin
they're accepting payments from
processors
who process the transaction from bitcoin
so it's not like mom and pop shop or a
restaurant
you know can't do they can you know
because of these processing companies
that do
you know take the bitcoin and then turn
it into cash for these guys so
i mean it's gonna become so much more
mainstream than it is now we've we've
heard more about bitcoin in the last
four or five months
than we have in the last four or five
years obviously it's going up but
man when you're talking about politics
and chaos less there's other things to
talk about and it's it's like we've
landed on stocks
the market and these big icons in the
industries
it's awesome it's awesome for them
listen all i can say is i love seeing
anybody that comes up with an idea
whether you believe it's going to happen
or not for them to succeed and go up
against the grain i salute
any one of them whether it's something i
support it or not if it's a positive
impact
and it's giving competition to the
market which crypto is doing
salute to everybody that's in the cl in
the crypto market okay so vegas
vegas benefits because you guys on vegas
has been crushed
you know i went to mgm to get a tour
there at grand arena the employee said
we let go of 200 employees they haven't
had a job nothing
is going on in the convention five
months ago when i went there five months
ago so vegas benefits as nevada eases
some chronovirus rules the tourist
destination built for excess
and known for bright lights big crowds
indulgent meals and headline shows
has slowly begun to reopen after the
pandemic halted business in march
nevada governor steve cissolack has
signed a
emergency order adjusting the minimum
distance between performance and
audience members that previously
challenged the return
of production to las vegas previously
performers were required to maintain 25
feet of space between audience
as a precaution against occur 25 feet i
mean that guy took it to a whole
different not six feet social distancing
25 i mean these
apparently these entertainers can spit
pretty long i mean they're
record-breaking spitters apparently
uh if that's even award so but some
smaller venues could not accommodate the
restriction the new emergency directive
effective immediately updates the
minimum distancing to six feet
if performers will wear masks if
performers were wearing masks and 12
feet if they're not wearing masks i mean
i cannot believe if performers can
imagine justin bieber performing with a
mask on
i mean it just makes no sense to me yeah
you know i i think
no city's probably been hit harder than
vegas i mean for las vegas to become a
ghost town that's depressing for this
country and that's what it was
literally for a long time i have a
friend that went there last week and he
says
they still have the bear they have a
plastic shield for you if you're playing
cards right
at the tables i think you can correct me
if i'm wrong if that's still the same
situation but um i think vegas is going
to rebound in such a big way because
this country you can tell the the the
the weight is kind of coming off
everybody's shoulder these vaccination
numbers even the doom and gloom
naysayers of the world the dr fosses of
the world can't scare people fast enough
over the optimism with all the um
vaccinations that are going on and i
think people are going to be spending
money
you know they're talking the economy is
doing okay they're talking about a four
percent
unemployment rate by the end of this
year so that means there's going to be
money out there to spend and i think
people
are going to make up for lost time so if
vegas is opening up a little bit right
now like for me i want to go out there
sooner than later because it's gonna be
so damn crowded
that it won't even be fun later in the
year but you know i like a
forward-thinking governor who knows
tourism is our number one thing
vegas runs this state we got to change
some rules to make it happen by the way
what's the social distancing
at some of these trip clubs i mean are
they have to stay 25 feet apart i mean
that probably
affects their cash flow i don't know how
do we go find out tom why don't we go
find out
i think the the biggest takeaway that
you can see going on with
news from vegas what's happening in the
markets
what's happening in the job sector is
that hospitality is back baby
like leisure travel hospitality will
make a
major return this summer i mean i was
out in south beach this weekend it's
like covet doesn't even
freaking exist down there clubs partying
packed i mean you can see the job
numbers
over here it's february jobs like
leisure and hospitality is back the
vaccinations come
vaccinations are in place you know 100
million americans have already had the
vaccine something like that
um by this summer let's say when the
weather starts getting nicer
you know a couple hundred million
americans are vaccinated
jobs are back i think covid knock on
frickin wood will sort of be a thing of
the past i think we'll still obviously
you know have certain restrictions and
certain um
you know ramifications having it but you
know the stock market
you start to see that the fang stocks
and the tech stocks the nasdaq's have
been getting crushed
for the past month why do you think that
is is because all the money is going
into
cruise lines airlines companies that
specialize in
hospitality because the stock market is
forward thinking not thinking about
what's currently happening
it's thinking about what's going to
happen in the next three to six months
and all indications are by the time this
summer hits
hopefully back we have a return to
normalcy and then here's the key
the key terminology that that uh tom
sort of touched on
and it's called pent up demand people
haven't been able to go out
party vacation in a freaking year we're
almost at like the one year mark
of everything shutting down and people i
don't know if that's true though you
partied
hardcore you partied hard yeah well it's
the gecko it's the gecko it'll you know
shout out to the gecko and paul over
there shout out to tom tom ellsworth's
mom babs it's her birthday today happy
birthday babs
babs is a good friend we once went on a
date with i think the lambo or the
ferrari i took her out
and we had a great time together she
loves speed i think she went bungee
jumping one time in her seventies
wow yeah pretty soon yes she is yeah
here's my question to you how excited
are you
to get back to a normal vegas type
experience
how excited am i to go back to a normal
experience vegas type experience like
what does that mean vegas chew it up are
you having a 21 year old vegas type
because i don't i don't know that
yeah vegas experience
bonanza greatest show on the internet
we're gonna be we're gonna be putting
the greatest that's what i'm talking
about baby what's up
grand arena we'll have 15 000 people at
mgm
grand arena in august and uh we're
excited about it we already announced
three speakers joe coy
comedian we'll be performing and then
we'll have patrick lencioni the
legendary author and then we have
frederick de silva
the number one illusionist in the world
he is ridiculous he'll be performing
very good
uh uh performer i've seen him do it
multiple times we've had him come out
multiple times
and then we have three other speakers
and entertainers one of the biggest
showmen in the world will be performing
on awards ceremony night it's a name
everybody around the world knows with
tens of billions of views
we'll be entertaining it's a massive
check but we're excited to have him
there as well
and then another person that everybody
around the world knows he officially
inked yesterday he signed yesterday
we're excited to announce some i think
april 7th i'll be announcing obviously i
can't say who it is but ipro7 i'll be
announcing
and so we're excited about it look
here's here's the thing about vegas man
there's something about vegas you know
all this thing about zoom like oh my
gosh business is only going to go from
working from home no it's
not you're not going to work from home
because i had a guy that i talked to 20
year old kid you remember that 120 year
old kid started crying saying i've been
in my basement
i made 150 000 the last 12 months but
i'm miserable
because we need what we need interaction
we need argument debate laughter jokes
how you doing what's going on sympathy
touch and feel
we need that we need we need each other
right even if it's strangers you're
going to a restaurant no one's sitting
here like the food here must suck you go
to a restaurant 28 people saying you're
like okay cool
i feel safe we feel safe being around
other people as well i'm excited about
it for
the folks in vegas uh lee a good friend
of mine
uh that runs a very good sized audio
visual company him and i've been going
back in for he's telling me pat things
are looking very very good another guy
named marshall who's been doing stuff
for us
for a long time we've spent millions of
dollars with these guys over the years
with av
they're saying things are headed in the
right direction in vegas and not just
vegas other places as well obviously
florida led the way when it comes down
to
anything to do with uh what do you call
it uh convention
sports bubbles sure you know they were
leading the way and it's good to see now
others follow and suit as well well i
know you're super excited for
what will happen in vegas and this might
be a good segue to that zoom uh
story that's in the news but something
that you talked about and you know
i'll use our friend tom here as a
um as a case test
a dummy if you will um you know
something that you've talked about
you're the buddy in the basement
something that you do here at
valuetainment at php is
pat sometimes you just pat shows up in
your office and goes
how you doing man what's up what's up
cool that's it
and that just someone just rolling up on
you just
checking in on you bud you're good cool
cool cool cool is so freaking powerful
man
especially from a ceo and people don't
get that these days
you know like pat shows up in your
office hey what's up just saying what's
up
and just that human interaction is
obviously what
we needed oh my god so just hey man just
all good look
like they're they're it's more than just
like you're like oh [ __ ] let me what's
up you know like
it just shakes you up a little bit we're
humans we're touching we're talking
this is this is needed just like you
know water food shelter human
interaction is
essential yeah i mean you mentioned the
zoom thing you know there's a thing
called zoom gloom
and it's real there's a stanford
professor that spent nine months looking
at this and and there's so much
evidence of why it's bad it is not good
we've all hit a breaking point and if
you think it's good for you you think
you like the freedom of not having
traffic
ultimately this is going to destroy a
lot of things in society
yesterday i'm on the plane coming out
here and like someone you have a little
interaction with someone you try to
smile at them it's gone they don't know
that you're smiling at them when you
have a mask
and that's one of the problems with zoom
too here's one of them it's unnatural to
be looking at yourself
that long and that's what you're doing
on a zoom call you're seeing yourself as
well and nobody looks at themselves
that long also you need to be moving
around during the day you need to
you need to have some sort of facial
expression or have some non-verbal
communication even if it's an eye roll
in a meeting if somebody says stupid
something stupid so the zoom thing you
know it's funny because zoom stock just
keeps going up and up and up and i'm
you know you can say what you want about
it but people have to get back to the
office that's why i think when twitter
came out and said hey you can work from
home for life
are you serious they must be sending sp
be able to save so much money
you know by not having these employees
come back to the campus for them to say
something like that it doesn't make any
sense
i think people will be flocking back and
wanting it and craving it you mentioned
that kid in the in the basement
you know let me ask you i got a crazy
question for you what is the biggest
selling point
okay okay you ever talked to folks who
said i'm never going to get married
yes i'm never going to get married i'm
going to be single for the rest of my
life what is
what is the selling point of staying
single the rest of your life i guess you
only have to answer for yourself or you
do whatever you want whenever you want
what else is it what else is the benefit
of being and by the way i'm not pointing
at you because that's not you you don't
want to be single during your life no
but when people that say they want to be
single the rest of their life what do
they say
yeah do what i want nobody tells you
what to do i come and go as i please i
don't
deal with the annoying kids changing
diapers drama
you know as many girlfriends
what do i need companionship for like
they're only
talking about the upside yeah okay who
you venturing exactly
who are you talking so now watch this
you know how people overly sell you on
being married
what's the selling point of marriage
come hang out with us like
like companionships yeah all this other
stuff right okay
you know what's the best way to describe
zoom and face to face
zoom you're single face to face you're
married
dude it's like i don't have anything i
just say what's going on all this stuff
we need marriage is relationship man
that's like how you doing how are you
feeling like even today
i walk in and tom's in the corner you
know pumping out a story he's writing
something like hey what's up
hey what's up pat and i'm like hey
what's going on so
i think i think the the the and when we
work face to face
what happens more more arguments more
challenges more differences
but that's called relationships yeah but
you also have more collaboration
and more things yeah so what i'm saying
is it comes with more conflict but it
also comes with
why we're human beings nasim taleb which
i don't know if you've read any of his
book he wrote anti-fragile skin in a
game
have you read any discussion let me tell
you if you start
one chapter you will read all of his
books
let me say this one more time if you
read one chapter of nassim taleb
go on amazon read a free chapter once
you do
prepare a couple hundred dollars because
you're gonna write we're gonna read
every single thing he ever wrote nasim
taleb right and he wrote skin in a game
anti-fraud a couple other books as well
huh black swan yeah so so when you when
you read this book there's a part of it
that he says
about you know anger take this
medication to not be angry take that
medication to not have temper take this
medication for this
he says you know he says when it rains i
feel a little bit depressed
when it rains he says guess what i want
to feel depressed
like i want to be a human being that
feels
depressed that it's a little bit gloom
you know it gets dark and all
he says when my team loses i want that
six
hour annoying upset feeling for no
reason i didn't lose any money i don't
get paid i'm not the athlete
but i want that frustration that my team
just lost i got to go to work tomorrow
face
johnny who's going to tell me i told you
we're going to lose he says i want that
feeling
he says when i'm angry i want to have
that feeling i don't want you to
eliminate a part of me being angry
because it's what makes me what
a human being right it's a human it's a
human being so i i think people are
looking forward to being human beings
again yeah and you can be a human being
in vegas all you want man
yeah people are gonna be dying too yeah
so so that's that part
with uh uh uh we covered that story as
well so what else we got here you know
let's talk about the the 1.9 trillion
dollars
uh what page is that on by the way do
you see it or no kai what page is the
stimulus on i thought it was is that the
price for that island that private
island
island do you actually have a picture of
the island or no
pull up the island it says politics oh
there you go okay i see politics
go to the island so folks if you're
looking at buying an island there's one
island on the market by the way jack
dorsey's tweet is what i wanted to go
next
uh so this island
let's see if i got it here where's the
island at kai
do you have it up the biggest private
island
that island right there is on the market
and they're starting it at what price
i think you said there was no minimum
bid yeah no minimum bid yeah so here we
go estimated
biggest private island southern bahamas
is about to hit the auction block and
there's no minimum bid the 730 acre
undeveloped island known as saint
andrews or little
ragged island is the bahamas southwest
and most largest privately held island
currently listed for
sale the estimated opening bid of 19.5
million dollars according to the auction
house holding sale
bidding opens on march 26 and it
requires a hundred thousand dollar
deposit the listing notes that the
island could be transformed into a
private home
or resort with enough space for an
18-hole golf course the island is 10
minutes
by boat from the tiny settlement of
duncan town
on nearby reggae island which has an
airstrip for private planes it's about
372 miles
south of uh 372 miles southeast of miami
so it's not far from here
uh tim mcgraw and faith hill listed
their 20-acre private island last month
on which they built a 6 500 square foot
home for 35 million the 430 acre private
island that comes developed
with five luxury villas a beach club and
a spawn of botox is now on the market
for 45 million
so what do you think about buying an
island like is there any dream to want
to own an island one day no
no because when i think of private
island i think of jeffrey epstein i
think if you have a private island
something bad is gonna happen
yeah i'm suspicious of people that want
private islands you're hiding something
plus i want amenities okay i don't want
the person that's landing my plane
the air traffic controller to also be
the delivery guy for uber eats and the
dry cleaner on the island okay
i want a developed country that has
infrastructure i don't want a private
island
i can live without it that's like doing
zoom all day having a private
trailer right give me a big city put me
in the middle and i'll be a hell of a
lot
i don't know if you can't say anything
because if you do you may be friends
with epstein because if you want to have
an island
i've just tagged everything on you so
would you want to have an island or no
for some reason the only like you're
thinking of jeffrey epstein the one
thing that i'm thinking of is the fire
festival i got my own i got my own
freaking island
i'm throwing a party and i'm ripping
people off but
who dreams of having their own island is
the is the dream of owning an island
shot based on what these guys just said
right now like are you like completely
done wanting an island sam wants one i
don't agree at all
you want an island no no
so how about you sam anything with an
island or no whatever who cares
kai you don't have an opinion on an
island no it's not on an island it's
cool i mean richard branson is the the
name where i go with private island i
mean he blocker island nick ryan
they got destroyed by a hurricane and no
i mean that's what's going to happen oh
you're if you don't want to die
you're setting yourself up in the
bahamas that something's going to happen
but uh you you own an island yeah
branson and then by the way i was at
hawaii a couple weeks ago and i was uh
right across right the island that we're
staying at
was uh ellison's island right right
there
that he had 98 of the island he owns
which pretty interesting 98 except the
beaches you know what else isn't on a
private island
a freaking hospital okay what happens if
you get bit by a shark on your private
island what the hell are you gonna do
you're basically saying it sounds good
in theory but in practicality just
sounds like crap
a lot of work if a similar if a friend
in your life
that's like the guy from couples retreat
comes to you and says him and his wife
are thinking about getting a divorce and
they're going to
an island couples retreat you and shonda
would not go to the married island you
wouldn't go to it you wouldn't want to
go there for like a week
i i can't go anywhere for a week number
one so that rule should be up shut up
that's out that is officially out yeah i
mean i think there's something about an
island i don't know i think
you're feeling the vibe the only thing
for me that i think about an island is
i think about recruiting people i care
about to live together on an
island like it's like listen if you got
all the money in the world you're 65 or
like listen you get your
20 best like you know couples that you
hang out with you're like like dude
what if we all build a home and we go
there and we build a little community
for ourselves and we just hang out
you know what would that look like you
know i think i think it'd be a fun
weekend i just don't know how you could
sustain it
i don't disagree with you i don't
disagree i don't think you're buying an
island to live on an island although
larry ellison is saying he's going to go
live on the island and leave california
but i don't know if that's going to be
let me tell you being a south florida
boy miami boy i only have like a few
islands in mind
fisher island star island hibiscus palm
island
south beach itself is an island like
that's the islands that i'm interested
that's what happens
royal family yes uh israel
the australian i am still thinking about
blake griffin going to the nets
that's still what i'm thinking about
does he have anything left do you think
yeah i think he does for being a number
four guy i think i think he's a good
number four guy i don't think someone's
got a rebound right no he's a good
number four guy
by the way he's actually got good shots
17 footer you know 18 footer he's
he's going to be a good fit for that
team he's going to be good fit for that
he's still one of the top
i think 20 highest player uh paid
players in the nba which is a rip-off
but that's the part of the league they
protect the players
look at the nfl dak prescott is now the
highest
security 120 122 guaranteed oh really
what do you think about that though
i i go to vtpose.com and you'll see how
i think about it
uh really post the story yeah that's the
story of ttpulse.com um
the headline's pretty good you'll have
to read the headline then you if you
read the headlines
you'll you'll know what i feel like
overpaid dallas cowboys to pay dac
prescott like he's amazon.com even
though he's winning
percentage resembles a usb that's you
and your titles man
that's kind of how i feel about it jerry
jones was backed into a corner he
had to do this well go to my last line i
think i had a good analogy at the end
i go because i was drawing i was saying
tom brady
has you know taken less money he's
wanted other talent there he doesn't
care how high
highly paid he is great if tom brady
were to be compensated based on dak
prescott's criteria he'd be worth almost
as much as the new school teacher
husband of jeff bezos ex-wife mckenzie
that's a great that is a good callback
so anyway so i think
he had to do it jerry jones had to sign
him but i tell you
i tell you in that part the one thing
about no matter how much people say
about jerry
there's one thing about jerry that's
very unique you know what it is he
doesn't
change quarterbacks that often once he
locks
onto if jerry believes in you jerry
believes in you like jerry's like
you know who was before uh prescott who
was a quarterback
tony romo tony romo like everybody said
dude trade him already he's like no i'm
sticking to it right even with all the
injuries yeah he's like well you know
press god you know you're
why you he's sticking with prescott
after injury pay him this kind of money
yeah and he overpaid because two years
ago he was going to pay 30 million years
so he ended up paying this contract so
there's a part of jerry
that you have to know no matter what
people say about jerry good for jerry
for doing what he did with that
hey by the way jerry made hundreds of
millions during that texas storm
he's invested in these energy companies
or oil somehow
if you look it up jerry jones really
really profited
um over those storms i love jerry i
think the cowboys have to be interesting
and exciting for the nfl to be great i
miss the cowboys being truly relevant
and i
i just don't think dak prescott is the
guy to make him that way so oh you don't
think that i don't think so
i think they are what they are i mean
they they might make the playoffs but
they're not going to do any damage so
i think you know they're stuck with him
for four years and they're not going to
be going to the zoo so
there's no way they're going to the
super bowl there's no way because his
contract is prohibitive to bring in 33
or like what's your no no it's less than
33 percent and
you know what my percentages are dead-on
you don't have attractiveness i am never
wrong
prince charles is going to give up the
crown after one month
and turn it over to william mark it down
tom's got a lot of predictions yeah
he's just blindly throwing darts not
blind no
no academy of
composition art collectors love my art
score you give 100 bucks
system that lets them put the into
number of quality of rpvd you probably
don't have time to check it out would
you send an email to info at
valuetainment maybe i'll take a look at
it if you send it
at info patrickdavid.com pat what's your
thoughts on darpa
creating cryptocurrency government would
not allow new currency
unless they have full control i mean i
that's again for me currency
is based on control that i see some of
these guys wanting to get involved in
they want to be able to control it
trump will buy that and bring his mega
fest to start his own
the island
12x12 said i just paid to say i love you
even you adam
and i meant it from the bottom of my
heart i
love you adam i love you too love you
okay you were going to say something
about prescott
before i interrupted you um am i the
only one here i love seeing the cowboys
lose
i love it you're steven i don't know why
but it's a lot of people
about them cowboys i love it it's a lot
of i just i didn't just
i did like the the michael irvin emmett
smith troy aikman
you know early 90s that there was some
swag but
every year people jump on the cowboy
this is our year and like
i don't know will jerry jones win
another super bowl before
his time you know the clock runs out
should i give you one
what do you mean all right answer the
question oh my god answer the question
then
adam jerry jones you have crossed the
line you've been
fantastic so many people well i mean
first of all stop getting so emotional
china hacks me i tell you the the
british empire's about to hack the hell
out of you
go ahead ted okay so you're not to
answer the question i
don't know well jerry jones is jerry
jones going to win another super bowl
before he dies i think so because he's
going to live to be 100.
and they have to get past this dak
prescott disaster and he's not
i like dak he's a good quarterback but
he's not great you're saying you're
agreeing with tom are you agreeing with
me
oh if whether they're going to win yes
i'm betting on he's going to win yeah
he's an ultimate winner everything he
does i'm betting he's going to win
so this was after the super bowl the the
year that the cowboys
beat it was the one they played they
beat pittsburgh okay so they win the
super bowl and i was i was there we were
doing our sunday night show live
on the field right after the super bowl
this is when i was working in chicago
and jerry jones couldn't have been
cooler we grabbed him right at 10 30
boom boom boom he's doing an interview
with him
so then we have just a few minutes left
in the show and i was gonna go into the
locker room and try to get some
interviews with a couple more players
so i'm waiting in line i finally get
into this cramped cowboys locker room
and out of nowhere this guy starts
calling my name he's going
my man and i my man we did it
and he's looking right at me and i
couldn't i go i was looking behind me to
see if
he must have been talking to somebody
else finally this guy is zeroing in on
me wait did i told you we were gonna do
it
it was deion sanders so he got me
confused with somebody else
so i thought to myself let me go over
there he clearly thinks i'm somebody
else
but let me run with this let me go try
to get an interview we can get him live
i go over he keeps he hugs me and did he
think it was chris bower
i don't know who he thought i was at the
time so this is classic so i go
we only have a couple minutes can you
come outside and do a quick interview he
goes my man you know my motto
if it don't make dollars it don't make
sense
he literally told me that line on the
spot
i don't know who he thought he was but
that was his way of not doing the
interview
if it don't make dollars it don't make
sense so that was his way of declining
and to this day i would love to find out
who he thought i was
because he knew you were he was like he
did not recognize the great uh thomas
jenner
really my my theory is maybe that was
chris fowler of espn i'm not
what do you put where do you put diana
i'm the greatest athletes of all time
he's got to be right up there when you
think about him playing in the super put
ahead of him
bojack greatest athlete you put ball
yeah a little bit
i i don't know an either statistic if he
did more than beyond it statistically
the one thing what was speed one was
strength oh no no no no no
dion was a 320 hitter he had a season
over here 320.
in baseball that ain't easy yeah to do
that and dion had what did bow hit
270. yeah yeah you know what the [ __ ]
you're saying
we'll never know with bo that's the
problem because you know he got injured
and it was over but
man they were both spectacular but dion
dion changed games i mean he completely
shut
down one half of the field that's true
because they would not even try to throw
to him back in the day
that was a private island right there
and he was a threat returning punts
and he was exciting i mean he was the
most exciting player in the league for
so long and we miss him
yeah he was and listen the one thing let
me just see this batting
cause banning average tells you if you
can make it or not like you know tebow
went in there
yeah he had three or four in a season
it's not easy hitting three or four in
the season bo jackson didn't hit 304 in
the season but beau was a great athlete
so
dion sanders if there's a guy imagine
racing with him 40 yard dash at his peak
they say he ran a
uh uh he ran a four one nine four four
one nine
is what he wrote a four one nine and
they no four two one
and they say bo ran a four one nine he
said bo just came in
said you're ready no stretching no
nothing ran for one night
and he left did you hear the the latest
story with deion sanders no he's you
know he's a
football coach for um small school
i think uh historically black college
yes yeah i forgot which one
he coached his first game they crushed
him they won
and then he came back to his locker room
retired and went into the hospital no no
he came back to his office all his stuff
was stolen his jewelry
his wallet his credit cards and it was
like
uh obviously uh he's like i gotta tell
you i did the press conference we won
the game and all that
but where's my [ __ ] someone stole my
[ __ ] yeah and like in the middle of the
press conference something to that
effect
it resurfaced and he's like nah nah i'm
playing that game someone stole my [ __ ]
and i don't know who it was
but there was some drama going on it
became the big story because he thought
he had his stuff stolen yeah and he made
the whole press conference about that
but then
they tried to say no no it was just a
mistake someone else accidentally took
it or whatever he wasn't buying no he's
like they're like
dionne how does it feel to win we won
the game or whatever where's my [ __ ]
thank god i'm wearing my chain right now
it'd be stolen too where's my [ __ ] he
must have had some expensive stuff that
he left without so tom why don't you
tell us about your book that's coming up
well thanks okay so here it is pat you
saw it standing here
so about a year ago i started writing
this book it was you know what it's like
to write a book it's a process it's a
journey this book is on daniel ponce de
leon
okay so a lot of you know of him but
maybe you don't
but you've seen him so he's a pitcher
for the st louis cardinals right now a
great guy
unbelievable human being so back in 2017
he was pitching in triple-a
for the memphis redbirds in iowa against
the iowa cubs
he the game started at one o'clock which
actually was a big part of this story
uh he gets hit in the head with a line
drive and he goes down now this made all
the newscasts it was played everywhere
he goes down there there was no bleeding
and he never really passed out but
inside the hemorrhaging was going on
so luckily the trainer was so smart and
got on the scene
immediately identified everything did
everything right they got him off he was
begging to stay in the game long story
short they get them off the field and
then
all hell breaks loose he's throwing up
you know they cut his uniform off they
get him to the hospital
emergency surgery shaved off part of his
skull doctors told him you will never
play baseball again which
seems to be a logical thing right now he
had just had a baby
he's a christian but really wasn't
living the life maybe exactly how he he
wanted to where he felt he should be
starts healing he's in intensive care
for over a week he starts healing okay
decides to try to keep playing baseball
his head finally heals too and he comes
back the next year and he's in the minor
leagues again so great success story he
defied the odds
gets called up into the majors in july
of 2018
in his major league debut against the
cincinnati reds he goes to the mound and
throws a
seven inning no hitter mlb.com calls it
the second greatest
debut in baseball history so then they
got the idea to write the book
i was one of the writers they were
considering there was a long process to
be selected
yeah and then i went out and spent some
time with daniel and i put the book
proposal together and then we ended up
selling it to hashet
and hachette books published it and it
comes out today march 9th is the day
you'll be seeing daniel on the news a
lot today
they're in jupiter florida as a matter
of fact not far from here i'm going to
go say hi to him today but
it's a brilliant book it's a great book
on his story just
and i think anybody can apply some of
this to their life
if you're an entrepreneur if you're if
you're anybody if you have family issues
if you anything like that anything can
be overcome when you can be in intensive
care and told you'll never play baseball
again and then to throw a no-hitter
in your major it's unbelievable the best
part is he's doing something with with
his life now
he's inspiring a lot of people and that
was the whole intent with this book
is to tell his story so it can help
people and that's all daniel wants to
accomplish with this and it was great
working with him and he's a
class act and a great guy and he's a
really good pitcher i mean he is one of
those power pitchers that strikes out a
lot of batters and now he's with the
cardinals
and he's going to be one of their top
players this year so it's out today it's
a great story how you can overcome any
kind of odds with faith
perseverance and hard work that's what
the bottom line is and that's something
we stand for valuetainment what we talk
about the best of comeback stories and
redeeming yourself redemption i just
added the link
there great story i said order tom's
book it's in the chat box kai let's put
it in the comment section as well
look if you follow the contest the
podcast we don't uh
sell you much we do maybe sponsorships
here and there when people ask us and we
like the products if you support us
i suggest you go support tom zenner and
buy the latest book that came out one
line drive uh the story of daniel daniel
ponce de leon with
tom zenner again we'll put the link
below if you support the podcast you
enjoy the podcast you like what we do
with vitamin
go order this book today just came out
today congratulations thank you so much
yeah and you guys got your copies you're
going to enjoy it i'll make sure you get
one adam too you'll love it
i know writing a book is emotional i
know writing a business book
is you're constantly working on it
writing a story like this you want to
get all the details right and it's
exciting when you finally have it and
with the
company like hashed hachette's got a
reputation as a uh publisher so it's
it's very exciting thank you guys i
appreciate it
yeah i wrote it during the pandemic at
the beginning of it really like the very
beginning of the pandemic every day
and real quick what's the connection
with jeff deutsch oh yeah so jeff
is a good friend of ours he's daniel's
manager
a former agent so all these worlds kind
of collided it's really crazy just the
the shrinking of the world is crazy
wine onelinedrive.com gives you a little
bit backstory
linedrive.com how old award one is
drive.com ponce is probably about 28 now
and you know what here's the funny thing
too because you know what it's like when
you have somebody that you work with to
write a book
you form a unique relationship and you
have to come up with whatever style
works for you and i know
he completely submerged himself into his
life when he you know did the book on
you daniel and i had our own way of
doing it that really seemed to work
but you know this was funny and i found
it ironic at the very beginning we have
the same birthday
and i just think that it's so bizarre
crazy yeah right i just think there's a
little bit of something to that which is
just crazy
um and he's from l.a so you know it's a
it's a big deal
tom zenner's birthday january 16th oh
you just same day as daniel
yeah we got him the cigar cigars and the
wine right
we didn't even hear about it was his
birthday it was his birthday
during the move we were moving well it
was during everybody having cove
is what the era was your podcast was
down
for several weeks thanks guys you know i
like to keep my birthday on the download
because my kids don't know how old i am
and i want to keep it that way 41.
you're you're young exactly
you're little it was really tough for me
just hitting 40 man i was still
depressed last year but then
i'm getting over it yeah we look great
buddy gang uh
once again episode 44 reminder for
everybody that we are doing
45 episode 45 this thursday at
9 00 a.m eastern standard time so we're
going to go an
hour test it this thursday to see what's
going to happen with west coast people
because they keep saying i want to be on
it live
can you go a little earlier we start
it's 5 a.m over there they would like it
to be 6
a.m when we start because they miss the
first hour and this
thursday we'll be having tom ellsworth
here with us so last time
this tuesday was tom so it's tom tom
maybe even babs makes an appearance
who knows who knows last week was sonata
and daniel de martina booth
and this week it's tom and tom okay let
me just say one last thing keep it
rolling
and the impact i'm seeing pat is
unbelievable i mean
i was out about the last few weeks and
valuetainers are out there just
pumping up the podcast they love it it's
just so bizarre when you're out there in
the world and you're seeing it so
credit to you for what you've built and
man it's getting big
yeah i mean this is just the beginning
you're that guy david ben patrick you're
kind of
just but when they see you they don't
even know your name they just say soy
boy
what's up you know you got the nickname
and we go take a shot of milk
if you enjoyed it smash that subscribe
button help us cross a hundred thousand
subscribers so we can potentially go to
three days
a week and with that being said we will
see you again next
this thursday coming up at 9 00 a.m put
it in your calendar 9 00 a.m eastern
standard time
which makes it 6 a.m pacific 9 a.m
eastern
this thursday take care everybody bye
bye bye bye
you